This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. I am invisible, understand, simply because people refuse to see me. So says the protagonist in Ralph Ellison's 1952 novel, Invisible Man. Readers never learn the character's name, but they're invited to experience his life. Walking down the street in Harlem, passers-by look right through him. Diligently working at a paint factory, his efforts go unnoticed. He joins a political organization, but he is treated as a pawn, a tool to advance the agendas of others. Ralph Ellison's novel was about the dehumanizing effects of racism, but the feeling of invisibility affects many people.
这里是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。我很隐形，懂吗，原因很简单，因为人们拒绝看到我。拉尔夫·埃里森 (Ralph Ellison) 1952 年的小说《隐形人》中的主角如是说。读者永远不知道这个角色的名字，但他们受邀去体验他的生活。走在哈莱姆区的街上，路人直接看穿了他。在油漆厂里勤奋工作，他的努力却无人注意。他加入了一个政治组织，却被当作一颗棋子、一个推进他人议程的工具。拉尔夫·埃里森的小说讲述的是种族主义的去人性化影响，但这种隐形的感觉却影响着许多人。
I recently met an older woman at one of the stops on a hidden brain live tour I've been doing across the United States. She told me that when she walks through a mall nowadays, people look right through her. It's as if she isn't there. In a 2023 advisory, former U.S. Surgeon General Vivek Murthy said that social isolation and feelings of invisibility profoundly affect workers in many fields. In a conversation on Hidden Brain,
我最近在美国各地进行 Hidden Brain 巡回演出时，在其中一站遇到了一位老妇人。她告诉我，如今当她走过商场时，人们直接把她看穿了。就好像她根本不在那里一样。前美国外科医生维韦克·穆尔蒂 (Vivek Murthy) 在 2023 年的一份咨询报告中表示，社交孤立和隐形感深深地影响着许多领域的劳动者。在 Hidden Brain 的一次访谈中，
he called loneliness an epidemic that is having profound implications for depression, heart disease, and public health. This week on Hidden Brain, and in a companion story on Hidden Brain Plus, the human need to be significant and what happens when this deep yearning isn't met. Also, how to help others be seen
他将孤独称作一场流行病，这场流行病对抑郁症、心脏病和公共卫生产生了深远的影响。本周的 Hidden Brain，以及 Hidden Brain Plus 上的配套故事，将探讨人类对被重视的需求，以及当这种深切的渴望无法满足时会发生什么。此外，我们还将探讨如何帮助他人被看见，
and be seen ourselves. As a species, humans have certain non-negotiable needs. We need air, we need water, we need food. Beyond these basics, however, we also have psychological needs. We need to feel like our existence matters that we are valued. Psychologist Gordon Flett remembers a moment like
以及让我们自己被看见。作为一个物种，人类有着某些不可妥协的需求。我们需要空气，我们需要水，我们需要食物。然而，除了这些基础需求之外，我们还有心理需求。我们需要感觉到我们的存在至关重要，我们的价值得到认可。心理学家戈登·弗莱特 (Gordon Flett) 回忆起他
in his own life. It started when his wife noticed something about his complexion. I woke up one day after having some pain and my wife said, you don't look good. Your skin is turning yellow. And if we found the hospital, they said, come in right away. And I had a problem
自己生活中的某个时刻。这一切始于他的妻子注意到他的肤色有些异样。有一天，在经历了一些疼痛后我醒来，我妻子说，你气色看起来不太好。你的皮肤在变黄。我们去了医院，他们说，马上进来。我遇到了一个
with bile duct issues where they figured, though, that if they address whatever blockage there was, that I would get better. Instead, I didn't get better. I started to get, went deep yellow in terms of Janus and eventually orange. And I'm talking pumpkin orange at one point, ended up losing 40 pounds, had four different
胆管问题，当时他们以为，只要处理好任何阻塞，我的情况就会好转。然而，情况并没有好转。我开始变黄，就黄疸而言变成了深黄色，最后变成了橙色。我说的甚至达到了南瓜橙的程度，最终体重减轻了 40 磅，经历了四次不同的
procedures where they thought they must have just missed something. And then eventually the one doctor who I ended up on his operating table who I'd never met, and he figured it out. I'd call my doctor house like the TV show. Because he figured out there was only one variable that was left and that was the IV that was going into me, how I had a weird interaction that actually had put me in liver failure for almost three weeks, being hooked up to IV. And when they took me off the IV or they replaced that with something else, then I started to get better to the point I was able, after three full weeks in the hospital, being able to go home.
手术，他们以为自己肯定是漏掉了什么。最后，我终于躺在了我从未见过的一位医生的手术台上，他找出了病因。我把我的医生叫作“豪斯医生”，就像那个电视剧一样。因为他发现只剩下一个变量，那就是输进我体内的静脉注射液，它产生了奇怪的副作用，实际上导致我的肝脏衰竭了将近三周，这就是插着静脉注射液的结果。当他们拔掉静脉注射液或者换成其他东西时，我的病情开始好转，在医院住了整整三周后，我终于能够回家了。
So on the very last day, I'm there at night. And a nurse comes in wearing a late night with David Letterman T-shirt. And she goes, you don't know me, but I know you, and I know what you've been through. And she says, your file is like three feet thick with all the tests that have been. and run on you, and you had a very close call. She goes, so I'm just here, I know you're medically okay now, and you're putting back the weight, and you're restoring some color. But I'm just here to make sure that you're okay in a mental health sense, that you're okay
所以在最后一天，我在那里待到晚上。一个护士走了进来，穿着一件印有大卫·莱特曼深夜秀的 T 恤。她说，你不认识我，但我认识你，我知道你经历过什么。她说，你的病历有三英尺厚，上面有为你做过的所有检查，你经历了一次非常危险的生死关头。她说，所以我来这里，我知道你的身体状况现在没问题了，你正在恢复体重，气色也在恢复。但我来这里只是为了确保你的心理健康状况没问题，确保你一切都好，
because it's quite a trauma you went through and some dark thoughts. So she sat with me for three hours. Wow. Two in the morning to five in the morning. Wow. And we talked about everything, life, the big picture, her brother with David Letterman's show, because that's where she got the T-shirt. And I thought, this is the essence,
因为你经历了一次相当大的创伤，可能会有一些黑暗的想法。于是她陪了我三个小时。哇。从凌晨两点到凌晨五点。哇。我们聊了一切，生活、宏观愿景，她在大卫·莱特曼节目组工作的兄弟，因为她的 T 恤就是从那里得来的。我想，这就是精髓所在，
what an ideal world it would be if medical people had the time and the resources to be able to sit there and say, I'm now giving patient care in terms of the person. I wanted to hugger at the time because I just thought, how does somebody be that in tune with what somebody needed at just that time?
如果医务人员有时间和资源能够坐在那里说，我现在是在对病人进行人格化的关怀，那将是一个多么理想的世界啊。当时我很想拥抱她，因为我只是在想，怎么会有人如此敏锐地捕捉到别人在那个特定时刻的需求呢？
And also the fear of knowing that this could happen again and trying to dispel some of that. So, you know, thanked her profusely at the time, and maybe she's still out there and she'll hear this segment. At York University in Canada, Gordon, who goes by Gord, studies the physical and psychological conditions that can help people flourish. He says interactions like the one he had with his nurse remind us that we matter, and mattering is a feeling that is vital to our well-being. God also researches what happens when we feel we don't matter. He remembers a time more than two decades ago when two students at a high school in Colorado
还有那种知道这可能会再次发生的恐惧，并试图消除其中一些恐惧。所以，你知道，当时我向她深表感谢，也许她还在某个地方，会听到这个片段。在加拿大的约克大学，戈登（大家叫他戈德）研究的是能够帮助人们蓬勃发展的生理和心理条件。他说，像他与护士之间的这种互动提醒我们，我们是重要的，而“重要感”是对于我们的幸福至关重要的感觉。戈德还研究了当我们觉得自己不重要时会发生什么。他记得二十多年前科罗拉多州一所高中的两名学生，
felt like they were invisible. Eric Harris and Dylan Klebold had families and a few friends, but they were obsessed with the notion that they didn't matter to the people who held the most power in their social world, the popular kids at school. Dylan's journals show a kid who felt like a ghost, wandering through the halls and feeling completely overlooked and ignored.
觉得自己就像隐形人一样。埃里克·哈里斯 (Eric Harris) 和迪伦·克莱伯德 (Dylann Klebold) 有家庭和几个朋友，但他们痴迷于这样一种观念：对于他们社交世界中拥有最大权力的人——学校里那些受欢迎的孩子来说，他们是无足轻重的。迪伦的日记展现了一个感觉自己像个幽灵的孩子，在走廊里游荡，感觉完全被忽视和冷落。
On the other hand, Eric felt he was actually better than everyone else, and it made him furious that no one recognized his greatness. They fed off each other's bitterness, eventually deciding that since they couldn't get the respect or attention they wanted through normal means, they would take it by force. To fix their feeling of being nobodies, they planned a tragedy that they hoped would make them the most famous names in the country. They didn't just want to commit a crime.
另一方面，埃里克觉得自己实际上比所有人都好，没有人认可他的伟大，这让他感到愤怒。他们助长了彼此的痛苦，最终决定既然他们无法通过正常途径获得想要尊重或关注，那他们就用武力夺取。为了解决他们作为无名小卒的感觉，他们策划了一场悲剧，希望这能让他们成为全国名气最大的人。他们不仅仅是想犯下一桩罪行。
They wanted to stage a massive, cinematic event that would be studied for decades. We now know that event as the 1999 Columbine High School shootings in which Eric Harris and Dylan Klebold killed 13 people and injured more than 20 others. More than a quarter century later, in 2025, the death toll was raised to 14, after a woman who was paralyzed in the shootings died of complications related to her injuries.
他们想要策划一场宏大的、具有电影质感的事件，以便被研究几十年。我们现在将这一事件称为 1999 年科伦拜恩高中枪击案，埃里克·哈里斯和迪伦·克莱伯德在该案中杀害了 13 人，并打伤了其他 20 多人。四分之一个世纪后的 2025 年，死亡人数上升至 14 人，此前一名在枪击案中瘫痪的女性因与其伤势相关的并发症而死亡。
Gordon Flett says the two killers at Columbine High School are an extreme example of a theory propounded by the social psychologist, Ari Kroglansky. People will go to extraordinary lengths to feel noticed, to feel significant. They decided that they would live in infamy by shooting at the school. And this idea comes from work by Kuglanski, the notion of people wanting to be significant by doing something, even though they realize that it will harm them and they'll no longer be with us, but they'll take means that are quite violent
戈登·弗莱特表示，科伦拜恩高中的这两名凶手是社会心理学家阿里·克鲁格兰斯基 (Arie Kruglanski) 提出的理论的极端例子。人们会不惜一切代价去寻求被注意到、被重视的感觉。他们决定通过在学校开枪来遗臭万年。这个想法来自于克鲁格兰斯的著作，即人们想要通过做某事来获得重要感，尽管他们意识到这会伤害他们，他们将不复存在，但他们会采取相当暴力的手段，
as a way of showing and proving their sense of significance and value, but in a very heinous way. You know, it's sad when it gets to this point that people don't get their attention satisfied through more positive means. Gordon has spent time reading the journals of the killers. He says they paint a chilling picture of social isolation and alienation. You see a lot of issues.
作为展示和证明其重要感和价值的一种方式，但却以一种非常十恶不赦的方式。你知道，当事情发展到这种地步，人们无法通过更积极的途径来满足他们对关注的需求时，这是令人悲哀的。戈登花时间阅读了这些凶手的日记。他说，这些日记描绘了一幅令人不寒而栗的社会孤立和疏离的图景。你会看到很多问题，
with self-worth, a feeling of a sense of being bullied and being ignored and ridiculed. A strong feeling that arouses both depression and anger is a sense of being humiliated. So often you'll see this and there are multiple accounts. There are differences between the two boys in terms of their personalities. But this was a theme of, you know, I'm not getting the respect. I deserve. I need to get some respect and you'll all do something you'll never forget. Typically, Gorton says, most of us seek to make our mark on the world by achieving something of value, by doing good deeds. Influencers might try to create a video that goes viral. Athletes might try to break some long-held record.
包括自我价值感、一种遭受欺凌、被忽视和嘲笑的感觉。一种能同时唤起抑郁和愤怒的强烈感觉就是羞辱感。你经常会看到这种情况，而且有多种记录。这两个男孩在个性方面存在差异。但这是一个共同的主题，你知道，我没有得到我应得的尊重。我需要获得一些尊重，你们所有人都会做出一件你们永远不会忘记的事。戈登说，通常情况下，我们大多数人都是通过取得有价值的成就、做善事来在世界上留下自己的印记。网红可能会尝试制作一段走红的视频。运动员可能会尝试打破某项长久保持的纪录。
Entrepreneurs might try to build a successful business. But if those means to achieve recognition are closed off to us, some of us turn to more drastic measures. Typically, it's the case of some form of mistreatment or being ignored or being misdural or being misdural. made to feel invisible that arouses these feelings of needing to be significant. And you can do that through positive ways of interacting with people, but you can also affiliate with people who are less than desirable and engage in antisocial behavior that will impact others. And this need to matter will become expressed when it's frustrated,
企业家可能会尝试建立一个成功的企业。但如果这些获得认可的途径对我们关闭，我们中的一些人就会转向更极端的措施。通常情况下，这是某种形式的虐待、被忽视、被错误对待或被塑造成隐形人，从而唤起了这种需要变得重要的感觉。你可以通过与人互动的积极方式来做到这一点，但你也可以与不太理想的人交往，从事会影响他人的反社会行为。而这种对重要感的需求在受挫时就会表现出来，
ideally in socially acceptable ways, but often in terms of delinquency, gang activity and so on. And I try to remind myself when things happen that are really troubling that, you know, everybody has a need to matter and that this will get expressed one way or the other. In August 2005, a huge storm hit the Gulf Coast of the United States. Hurricane Katrina, of course, caused devastating flooding and widespread destruction across Louisiana, Mississippi, and Alabama. In the aftermath of the disaster, people, had many basic needs. They needed shelter, they needed food, but they also needed to feel like they weren't abandoned. Talk about this idea that after a mass disaster, a huge problem,
理想情况下是通过社会可接受的方式，但通常是以违法犯罪、黑帮活动等形式表现出来。每当发生真正令人烦恼的事情时，我都会提醒自己，你知道，每个人都有被重视的需求，这种需求总会以这样或那样的方式表达出来。2005 年 8 月，一场巨大的风暴袭击了美国墨西哥湾沿岸。当然，卡特里娜飓风在路易斯安那州、密西西比州和阿拉巴马州造成了破坏性的洪灾和广泛的毁灭。在灾难过后，人们有许多基本需求。他们需要庇护所，需要食物，但他们也需要一种自己没有被抛弃的感觉。谈谈这个想法，在经历了一场大规模灾难、一个巨大问题之后，
as a collective, we can feel like we need to matter. Yes, and I think a key time for that sense of mattering is when you really do need people to step up and show you some comfort and some support. And the example of Hurricane Katrina and the events in New Orleans and the accounts that people have of feeling abandoned really stuck with me because, in fact, I was at a conference not too long before that. And I know there was stories of people going to the casino, which I went to with a friend who thought she'd lost her purse there. And the notion of locking the doors and not opening the doors on people who are desperate for some safety really troubled me in terms of the accounts that I heard. So this is when you'll feel the sense of not mattering quite acutely when
作为一个集体，我们会觉得自己需要被重视。是的，我认为这种重要感的一个关键时刻，正是当你真正需要人们挺身而出，向你提供一些安慰和支持的时候。卡特里娜飓风的例子、新奥尔良发生的事件以及人们感到被抛弃的种种记录深深地触动了我，因为事实上，就在那之前不久，我曾参加过一个会议。我知道有一些故事讲述人们去赌场，我和一个以为自己的钱包丢在那里的朋友一起去过那里。对于那些极度渴望获得某种安全感的人，把门锁上、不为他们开门的这种做法，根据我听到的那些记录，让我感到非常困扰。所以，正是在这种时候，当你处于需求之中，而别人却把你当作无足轻重、可有可无、毫无价值的人来对待时，你才会非常强烈地感受到那种不被重视的感觉。因此，我认为绝对至关重要的是，当人们处于低谷并需要帮助时，要表现出那种感觉，嘿，你要认识到他们正在经历的事情，并在他们的绝望、压力甚至可能是创伤升级和放大之前提供这种安慰。你知道，几年前，前美国外科医生维韦克·穆尔蒂 (Vivek Murthy) 在 Hidden Brain 上与我们交谈过，他描述了自己访问密歇根州弗林特市的一段经历，当时正值那里的人们遭受了重大水质污染不久。我记得他告诉我的一件事是，人们非常绝望，不仅仅是希望他们的供水问题得到解决，而是渴望一种感觉：世界并没有继续前行，世界实际上停下来注意到正在发生的事情，并说我们认可并感同身受你们正在经历的事情。
you're in need and then somebody's treating you as if you're insignificant, expendable, worthless. So it's absolutely critical, I think, to show when people are really down and needing help, that sense of, hey, you're recognizing what they're going through and providing that comfort before it escalates and magnifies their despair, their stress, and even maybe trauma. You know, a few years ago, we had former U.S. Surgeon General Vivek Murthy talking to us on Hidden Brain, And he was describing a time when he visited Flint, Michigan, and this was shortly after, you know, people there suffered from a major contamination in the water supply. And one thing I remember he told me was that people were desperate, but not just for their water supply to be fixed, but for the sense that the world was not moving on, that the world actually stopped to notice what was happening, to say we recognize and we empathize with what you're going through.
是的。任何与人合拍、像他这样的人都会知道，在最基础的层面，我们需要知道我们是重要的，尤其是当我们被弄得觉得自己不重要的时候。不幸的是，有些人极度需要知道自己是重要的人，因为他们的一生都在被边缘化、被忽视和被边缘化为隐形人，以至于即使当有人最初向他们伸出援手时，他们也可能会说，好吧，你知道，这不过是老一套而已，却没有意识到某人对他们的福祉有着真诚的关心。除了我们在生物学意义上生存所需的基本条件之外，人类还需要觉得自己是有价值的和特殊的。特别是在我们遇到麻烦或痛苦时，重要的是要感觉到我们并不孤单，我们身上发生的事情对其他人来说是重要的。当我们回来时，我们将探讨渴望被看到、被听到、被关心的冲动，以及觉得自己不被关注的后果。
Yeah. And anybody who's in tune with people like he would know that at a basic level, we need to know that we matter, especially when we've been made to feel like we don't matter. And unfortunately, some people are really needing a lot to know that they matter because they've got such a life of being marginalized and ignored and invisible that even when somebody's initially reaching out, they might say, well, you know, that's just more of the same, not realizing that somebody has a sincere interest in their well-being. Above and beyond what we need to survive in a biological sense, human beings need to feel valued and special. When we are in trouble or in pain, in particular, it's important to feel that we are not alone, that what happens to us matters to other people. When we come back, the urge to feel seen and heard and cared about, and the consequences of feeling like we are not.
你在收听的是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。这里是 Hidden Brain。我是 Shankar Vedantam。戈登·弗莱特 (Gordon Flett) 是加拿大约克大学的心理学家。他研究的是人们茁壮成长所需的心理条件。戈德，在你生命中的早期，你很幸运地有过许多感觉自己被看到、被听到、被重视的经历。但我听说，特别是围绕着你的祖母，让你觉得自己像个小名人。能跟我讲讲那个故事吗？好的，好的。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Gordon Flett is a psychologist at York University in Canada. He studies the psychological conditions that people need in order to thrive. Gort, early in your own life, you were fortunate enough to have many experiences of feeling like you were seen and heard and valued. But I understand that being around your grandmother in particular made you feel like a mini celebrity. Tell me that story. Yes, yes.
还有我的姐姐卡伦（她已经去世了），但我是长孙，所以这自然而然地带来了一种特殊感。我会在夏天以及各种日子里去我祖父母家度过，那里离我们住的地方不远。我们会在工作日去路上的咖啡馆看望两位祖母，那家咖啡馆由我的一个祖母——住在那里的一位——以及我的另一个祖母共同经营。所以当我和姐姐去的时候，
me as well as my sister Karen who since his past, but I was the firstborn grandchild, so that automatically comes with a specialness. And I would spend summers and various days down at my grandparents' place, which was not too far from where we lived. And we would go down to on weekdays to visit both grandmothers at the cafeteria up the road, which was run by my one grandmother, the one who lived there, and my other grandmother as well. So when my sister and I would It was literally like, where's the red carpet? It was the only thing that was missing. Here they come.
字面上的感觉就像是，红毯在哪里？唯一缺的就是这个。他们来了。
And, you know, on top of all the attention, which is critical of the sense of mattering, is people showing an interest in you, lighting up when you come in, you know, a sense of attention to you, getting their full attention. On top of that, we could order anything we wanted because it was my grandmother's cafeteria. So for me, that was usually macaroni and cheese and chocolate milk. And, you know, but that's not why we wanted to go. whether they're the most, it was just that incredible. And, you know, all the people that worked for my grandmother as well, including my other
而且，你知道，除了所有这些对重要感至关重要的关注之外，还有人们对你表现出兴趣、当你进来时眼睛放光，你知道，那种全神贯注于你的感觉，得到了他们全部的注意力。最重要的是，我们可以点任何我们想吃的东西，因为那是我们祖母的咖啡馆。对我来说，那通常是通心粉加奶酪和巧克力牛奶。而且，你知道，但这并不是我们想去的原因，无论它们是不是最好的，只是那种感觉太棒了。而且，你知道，所有为我祖母工作的人，包括我的另一个
grandmother, you know, it was really like, as you said, being like a celebrity. And so when I came into this field, I started to think, well, you know, I've been fortunate and it took me a very long time to realize other kids weren't so fortunate, but we were. So when you went to this cafeteria guard, it wasn't just your grandmothers who were rolling out the red carpet. But it sounds like it was everyone who was there. Yeah, yeah. There was a staff of about six or seven people,
祖母，你知道，真的就像你说的，就像个名人一样。所以当我进入这个领域时，我开始想，好吧，你知道，我很幸运，而且我花了很长时间才意识到其他孩子没有那么幸运，但我们很幸运。所以当你去这家咖啡馆时，戈德，不仅仅是你的祖母们在铺红毯。听起来好像是在那里的每个人。是的，是的。那里大约有六七名员工，
but also people who work there were getting their lunch. And Mike, they said, oh, we told everybody you were coming. And it's like, you know, and, you know, ideally you have at least one person like that. You know, Yuri Bronfenbrenner, the famous social scientist, who was involved for many years trying to make things better in the U.S. and elsewhere. where he said every kid needs at least one special person who makes that kid feel like they can do no wrong, essentially, as their champion.
还有在那里吃午饭的人。麦克，他们说，哦，我们告诉所有人你要来了。这就像是，你知道，而且，你知道，理想情况下你至少有一个这样的人。你知道，著名的社会科学家尤里·布朗芬布伦纳 (Yuri Bronfenbrenner) 多年来一直致力于改善美国及其他地方的状况，他说过，每个孩子都需要至少一个特殊的人，让那个孩子觉得自己永远不会犯错，本质上就是他们的拥护者。
But I think we also need that as adults, too. We need somebody in our life who sees something special in us and who really believes in us in a way that maybe other people have overlooked. So many years after those memorable experiences at that cafeteria, you were sitting in a library reading a textbook as part of your graduate studies in psychology, and you came across this term that was new to you. What was this term? Give me the context court.
但我认为我们成年人也需要这样的人。我们的生活中需要有这样一个人，他能看到我们身上某些特别的东西，并真正以一种或许被其他人忽略的方式相信我们。在那个难忘的咖啡馆经历多年之后，你坐在图书馆里，作为心理学研究生学习的一部分，正在阅读一本教科书，然后你遇到了这个对你来说是全新的术语。这个术语是什么？给我讲讲当时的背景，戈德。
Sure. Well, we're talking about the term mattering. And I'm reading this chapter in this book by Morris Rosenberg, who originated the term and the focus on mattering. And about five pages of an overall chapter, he said this might be the most important element of the self-concept, particularly for people of certain ages, adolescence in particular with all the identity issues, the need for reassurance, and also when we get older or when we might feel that we're being
当然。嗯，我们谈论的是“重要感”（mattering）这个术语。我在读莫里斯·罗森伯格 (Morris Rosenberg) 的书中的这一章，他创造了这个术语并开启了对重要感的研究。在整体章节的大约五页中，他说这可能是自我概念中最核心的要素，特别是对于特定年龄的人来说，特别是处于各种身份认同问题、对安心的需求的青春期，以及当我们变老时，或者当我们觉得自己在那个时候
lost in the shuffle at that point. One of the things that Morris Rosenberg wrote was to believe that the other person cares about what we want, think, and do, or is concerned with our fate, is to matter. So that's how he defined what mattering was. Yes, yes. And there's so much in those three lines. If somebody said to me, pick two quick words to say what is mattering. somebody cares about you and somebody appreciates you.
被淹没在人群中时。莫里斯·罗森伯格写下的其中一句话是：相信另一个人关心我们想要什么、想什么、做什么，或者关心我们的命运，就是重要。这就是他对重要感的定义。是的，是的。这三行里包含着太多的内容。如果有人对我说，用两个简短的词来概括什么是重要感。就是有人关心你，并且有人欣赏你。
And not just for what you do, but who you are. Cares about you as a person, cares about you, and appreciates you as a person. I often think about people who are in such important jobs and they get burned out and dejected. And I thought they've lost sight of the fact that they're cared about, not just in terms of what they offer people, but also in terms of who they are. One of the fascinating things that Morris Rosenberg and others have noticed is that there's almost a cyclical pattern in mattering. So we can matter a lot when we're small children because, of course, we can be the apples of our parents' eyes. But then when we hit adolescence, we sometimes might experience a trough.
不仅仅是因为你做什么，而是因为你是谁。作为一个人关心你，关心你，并作为一个人欣赏你。我经常想到那些从事如此重要的工作却精疲力竭、沮丧不已的人。我想他们忘记了一个事实，那就是他们是被人关心的，不仅在于他们为人们提供什么，还在于他们是谁。莫里斯·罗森伯格和其他人注意到的一件迷人的事情是，重要感中几乎存在一种周期性的模式。所以当我们是小孩子时，我们可以非常重要，因为当然，我们可以是父母眼中的掌上明珠。但当我们步入青春期时，我们有时可能会经历一个低谷。
And again, when we are adults and we have careers and the careers are thriving, we can again experience a peak. But then as we retire and as we move into our retirement years, we can experience another trap. So it's not like mattering is one linear thing across the lifespan. It often has this pattern of waxing and waning. Yes, it can fluctuate because you're not always in your grandmother's cafeteria. And one transition that we focused on was moving from elementary school to high school, where you might suddenly feel like you're lost in the crowd. You had special teachers and friends, and now you're just in a sea of other people.
同样，当我们成为成年人并且拥有蓬勃发展的职业生涯时，我们又会经历一个巅峰。但随着我们退休并进入退休岁月，我们可能会经历另一个低谷。因此，重要感并不是贯穿整个生命周期的单一线性事物。它通常呈现出这种此消彼长的模式。是的，它会波动，因为你并不总是待在你祖母的咖啡馆里。我们关注的一个转变是从小学过渡到高中，在那里你可能会突然觉得自己淹没在人群中。你曾有特殊的老师和朋友，而现在你只是其他人海中的一员。
So there's immediate challenges, and that's why it's important for any efforts on mattering promotion to try and get to what I call deep mattering, where you know that despite the world going to hell and feeling that things are going to hell in your own life, that you still have those people in your life who care about you who can be sort of like your touchstones in terms of your sense of worth. And you still want to have as part of that identity that people care about you and appreciate you and indeed will not forget you. you. So when we don't have this feeling that we matter, when we feel invisible, you say that this can produce very powerful effects. Talk about the effects of not mattering on social anxiety cord. First of all, I should say that when we talk about not mattering and the pain as opposed to the joy of mattering, we talk about a concept called anti-mattering, which is that sense of feeling invisible,
所以有直接的挑战，这就是为什么任何促进重要感的努力都至关重要，要努力达到我所说的“深层重要感”，在那里你知道，尽管世界正走向地狱，并且觉得你生活中的事情正走向地狱，但你的生活中依然有那些关心你的人，他们可以成为你寻找价值感的精神支柱。你仍然希望将这一点作为身份认同的一部分，即人们关心你、欣赏你，并且确实不会忘记你。所以，当我们没有这种我们很重要的感觉，当我们感到隐形时，你说这会产生非常强大的影响。谈谈不重要感对社交焦虑的影响，戈德。首先，我要说的是，当我们谈论不重要感以及痛苦（与重要感的快乐相对）时，我们讨论的是一个叫做“反重要感”（anti-mattering）的概念，也就是那种感到隐形、
insignificant, unimportant, and in the case of social anxiety, it's very easy to be too convinced that other people are going to see you in a particular way. There's a fear of negative evaluation that drives a lot of social anxiety. But here, with a mattering focus, it would be the fear of a negative evaluation in terms of people don't even think about me, or if they do, they just see me as somebody who's irrelevant, who's unimportant. And as a result of that, you can become very avoidant because you're just expecting you're going to find more of that treatment waiting for you if you happen to encounter these people. So there's a lot of advance isolation with people who are socially anxious because they've got a negative expectancy. And that expectancy includes, I'm not going to be significant.
微不足道、不重要的感觉，而在社交焦虑的情况下，人们很容易过分确信其他人会以某种特定方式看待你。对负面评价的恐惧驱动着许多社交焦虑。但在这里，如果聚焦于重要感，那就是对负面评价的恐惧，担心人们甚至不会想到我，或者如果他们想到了，他们也只把我视为一个无关紧要的、不重要的人。正因为如此，你可能会变得非常逃避，因为你只是预料到，如果你碰巧遇到这些人，你会发现更多的这种对待方式在等着你。因此，对于有社交焦虑的人来说，会有很多提前的孤立，因为他们有着消极的预期。而这种预期包括：我不会是重要的。
I'm going to be seen as somebody who's less than important. Are you saying in some ways that as people perceive that they are not important in the eyes of others, in some ways they become less important in their own eyes, that it triggers self-criticism, self-hatred? Yes, it does, I think especially for young people and perhaps older people as well, that the feeling of not mattering is used as a self-evalentive cue. So you have the self-criticism and even self-hatred, but you're also confronted with, hey, my life's not going the way it is supposed to go, and it must be something about me.
我会被看作是一个无关紧要的人。你是说在某种程度上，当人们察觉到自己在别人眼中并不重要时，在某种程度上他们在自己眼中也变得不那么重要了，这会引发自我批判、自我厌恶？是的，确实如此，我认为特别是对年轻人和可能的年老者来说，不重要感被用作了一种自我评估的线索。所以你有了自我批判甚至自我厌恶，但你同时也要面对：嘿，我的生活没有按预期的方向发展，这一定是我自身出了什么问题。
And what happens is, sadly, people internalize what they see as the messages in their life so that they can now not matter to themselves. So the key that I try to say to younger people is know that when you're going to get this, you're going to be getting it through messages on the Internet, social media. The key is not to internalize it. So people who feel like they don't matter also end up experiencing more conflict with their friends and family members. What's the connection here, Gord?
而发生的事情是，可悲的是，人们内化了他们生命中所看到的那些信息，以至于他们现在对自己而言也不重要了。所以我试图对年轻人说的一个关键是，要知道当你遇到这些时，你将通过互联网、社交媒体上的信息来接受它们。关键是不要去内化它们。所以那些觉得自己不重要的人，最终也会与他们的朋友和家人经历更多的冲突。这里的联系是什么，戈德？
I think it's a detachment. Sometimes people are carrying around in anger or resentment. You know, how can they treat me like this? And that will spill over in terms of daily interactions where there'll be a low level of anger or hostility. And we did show in some of our research on this with just self-report measures that when asked to rate themselves in terms of daily experiences,
我认为这是一种疏离感。有时人们怀揣着愤怒或怨恨。你知道，他们怎么能这样对待我？这会蔓延到日常互动中，表现为低水平的愤怒或敌意。我们在对此的一些研究中通过自我报告测量确实表明，当被要求根据日常经历对自己进行评级时，
that those with a higher level of antimatter, said they had more conflict and less positive engagement with other people. And, you know, what would happen if you're very sensitive to that is then you'll become more removed from other people and more aloof, and you might actually be generating some of those interactions by people saying, why is this person being so standoffers to me? And to remember that it's an interaction between two people or more in a dyad. And, you know, you can generate your own stress by the way that you're responding to how you think other people are seeing you.
那些反重要感程度更高的人表示，他们有更多的冲突，与他人的积极互动更少。而且，你知道，如果你对这一点非常敏感，那么你就会与他人更加疏离、更加冷漠，你实际上可能会通过人们的反应来引发其中一些互动，比如他们会问：为什么这个人对这么冷淡？要记住，这是两个人或多人在二元关系中的互动。而且，你知道，你可以通过你回应他人看待你的方式来制造你自己的压力。
So it's almost like a vicious cycle. I think that I don't matter to you. Maybe in response, I derogate you or I hold you at some distance. You perceive me now as being standoffish, and now I have even more evidence that I don't matter to you. Yeah, and I can go on to the point where somebody can feel so isolated and alone. This is a big thing about that mindset and that interaction pattern is that there are some people who then say, I don't matter to anyone. and, you know, in fact, they do, but this is what they've convinced themselves of.
所以这几乎就像是一个恶性循环。我认为，我觉得我对你并不重要。也许作为回应，我贬低你或者与你保持一定距离。你现在觉得我冷淡，现在我有了更多的证据证明我对你不重要。是的，这种情况会一直发展下去，直到某人感到如此孤立和孤独。关于这种心态和互动模式，有一个大问题，那就是有些人会说，我对任何人都不重要。
So that's why it's critical. That's one caring person at least shows them that they do matter, so they at least don't go into the I don't matter to anyone mode and can start to look at things in a more differentiated way. What's the relationship between not mattering and depression and substance abuse? Yes, there's extensive research on the depression side and a little bit of research so far in terms of substance abuse. We just published a new meta-analysis showing that anti-mattering across about 20 studies or so
而且，你知道，事实上他们是的，但这是他们说服自己相信的。这就是为什么至关重要的是，至少有一个关爱的人向他们表明他们确实很重要，这样他们至少不会陷入“我对任何人都不重要”的模式，并开始以更具区分度的方式看待事物。不重要感与抑郁和药物滥用之间的关系是什么？是的，关于抑郁方面有大量的研究，而在药物滥用方面到目前为止只有少量的研究。我们刚刚发表了一项新的元分析，表明在大概 20 项左右的研究中，反重要感
strongly associated with depression, even more so than the positive feeling of mattering being linked with less depression. There are a few studies now linking not mattering with addictive tendencies, including social media addiction. And there I would look at it as these are people who have likely internalized the feeling of not mattering so that they've got into the sort of the what the hell, I'll do whatever I want because I don't have much happening and I don't see a positive future. So I'll do whatever that is and not worry about the consequences. So there's the most extensive research so far has been focused on two themes, the link between the feeling and not mattering and depression and the link between the feeling of not mattering and loneliness. Every time I read the statistics on suicide guard, I'm really
与抑郁强烈相关，甚至比重要感的积极感觉与减少抑郁的联系还要紧密。现在有一些研究将不重要感与成瘾倾向（包括社交媒体成瘾）联系起来。在那里，我会这样看：这些人很可能已经内化了不重要感，以至于他们陷入了类似“管他呢，我想做什么就做什么，因为我没有发生什么好事，我也没有看到一个积极的未来”的心态。所以我才不管后果如何，想做什么就做什么。因此，迄今为止最广泛的研究一直集中在两个主题上：不重要感与抑郁之间的联系，以及不重要感与孤独感之间的联系。每次我读到关于自杀的统计数据，戈德，我都非常
taken aback, some 50,000 people die by suicide in the United States every year. I'm sure the number is high in Canada as well. And of course, worldwide, I think the statistics suggest that more than 700,000 people a year kill themselves. Is there a connection between a feeling of not mattering and extreme actions like attempting or contemplating suicide? Yes, there is. It's shown both in terms of research as well as in case studies. And in terms of the research, there's about 10 studies. now that show the link between the feeling and not mattering, especially with our anti-mattering scale and suicidality. And some of these people also tend to be perfectionistic, where they feel that too much has been expected of them, and they feel that they don't matter. And the sad part is,
大吃一惊，美国每年大约有 50,000 人死于自杀。我确信加拿大的数字也很高。当然，在世界范围内，我认为统计数据表明每年有超过 700,000 人自杀。不重要感与企图自杀或考虑自杀等极端行为之间是否存在联系？是的，确实有。研究和案例研究都表明了这一点。就研究而言，大约有 10 项
often with people who have clearly reached some conclusion that they don't matter, they've convinced themselves that they're so insignificant. But importantly, I have to point out that the main slogan of the suicide prevention program in the United States is you matter. And that slogan was out there before any research was done. And I think it was because people realized that there's a life-saving potential to showing somebody that they matter and also finding a way to get the people to feel that sense of mattering so that they're not going to get to that point. And it's so uplifting when somebody says, I'm not feeling great today, I don't matter. And then legions of people jump in saying, yes, you do, you can call me, you know, total strangers or people that know them.
研究现在显示了不重要感（尤其是通过我们的反重要感量表测量）与自杀倾向之间的联系。其中一些人往往也具有完美主义倾向，他们觉得别人对他们的期望太高，并且觉得他们自己并不重要。可悲的是，
And I'm convinced that there's an enormous potential here for suicide prevention, where it's not just a slogan where the promotion of the feeling of mattering and how to reach out to people when you're feeling like you're feeling psychological pain and wondering about your significance, that could work wonders in terms of saving many of the people that you referred to. And it's important to note here, for anyone who may be struggling with thoughts of suicide, help us just a call or text away. In the United States, listeners can reach the suicide and crisis lifeline by calling or texting 988.
通常对于那些显然已经得出自己不重要这一结论的人来说，他们已经说服自己认为自己是如此无足轻重。但重要的是，我必须指出，美国自杀预防计划的主旨标语是：你很重要。这条标语在任何研究开始之前就存在了。我想这是因为人们意识到，向某人展示他们很重要具有拯救生命潜力，并且也能找到一种方法让人们感受到那种重要感，这样他们就不会走到那一步。当有人说“我今天感觉不太好，我不重要”时，这是多么令人振奋，随后大批的人蜂拥而至，说：不，你很重要，你可以打电话给我，你知道，完全是陌生人或者是认识他们的人。我深信，自杀预防在这里有着巨大的潜力，它不仅仅是一个标语，而是通过促进重要感，以及当你在经历心理痛苦、怀疑自己的价值时如何向他人求助，这可以在拯救你刚才提到的许多人的生命方面创造奇迹。对于任何可能正在与自杀念头作斗争的人来说，有一点很重要，那就是寻求帮助只需一个电话或一条短信。在美国，听众可以通过拨打或发短信 988 来联系自杀与危机生命线。
For those outside the U.S., there's a link in today's show notes with information on how to connect with support in your country. Gord, we hinted at this a little while ago, but research suggests that our unmet need to feel like we matter is linked to aggression and violent behavior. We talked about the Columbine school shootings, but I feel like almost every time there's a report of a mass shooting or a school shooting, it invariably transpires that the shooter was socially isolated or felt humiliated and ignored for years. And sadly, you know, when you think about it, when people are at the point where they're willing to do something where they will no longer be with us, it clearly is something that it means that they've lost the sense of mattering in a positive way. The way I talk about it is, well, you know, you've got an incredible double-edged sword here. There's the joy and the happiness and the sense of contentment and engagement that comes from feeling
对于美国以外的人，今天的节目简介中有一个链接，其中包含有关如何联系您所在国家/地区支持的信息。戈德，我们不久前稍微暗示过这一点，但研究表明，我们渴望感觉自己很重要的未满足需求与攻击性和暴力行为有关。我们讨论了科伦拜恩校园枪击案，但我觉得几乎每次有关于大规模枪击或校园枪击的报道时，最终总是表明凶手在社会上被孤立，或者多年来一直感到受辱和被忽视。可悲的是，你知道，仔细想想，当人们到了愿意做出某种让他们将不复存在的行为时，这显然意味着他们已经失去了以积极方式感受重要感的能力。我谈论这一点的方式是，好吧，你知道，这里有一把不可思议的双刃剑。一方面是快乐、幸福以及由于觉得
like others see you as important and paying attention to you. But the flip side is the pain of the feeling of not mattering or the fear of becoming someone who doesn't matter. And then that can be channeled in many different directions, often turned against oneself, but sometimes it's turned against other people. and, you know, in that case, anything goes because of that sense of not having a concern about the future other than being somebody who's remembered. But it's a remarkable thing in terms of the intense feeling both for the positive when you feel like you matter, but everybody knows what it feels like when somebody seems to go out of their way to make you feel like you don't matter.
别人视你为重要人物并关注你而产生的满足感和参与感。但另一方面是不重要感的痛苦，或者是害怕成为一个不重要的人。然后这种情绪可以被引导到许多不同的方向，通常是转向针对自己，但有时也会转向针对其他人。而且，你知道，在这种情况下，由于不再关心未来（除了作为一个被记住的人之外），任何事情都可能发生。但就积极方面的强烈感觉而言，这是一个显著的事情，当你觉得自己很重要时，每个人都知道当有人似乎故意让你觉得自己不重要时是什么感觉。
And if you have a life like that, eventually you can build up the kind of resentment that potentiates many of these acts. So in some ways people are saying, you know, I feel like I don't matter, but I'm going to prove to you that in fact I do matter and I'm going to do it, you know, at the point of a gun. Yeah, exactly. It's like you're going to say, okay, you know what, I do matter. You people were mistaken about me and you're going to get the thing this to remember by. And it's so sad because, you know, innocent people who have nothing to do with this person are lost in the process. And that just should be. shows you how personal mattering is. I say, you know, it's something that's modifiable, but it's something that's very, very personal. And it's not the same as belonging. Belonging is you have a place at the table. I say mattering is, do they hear your voice when you're at that table or do they ignore you and talk over you at that table? So it's not the same as belonging. It's not the same as social support. It's that core sense of worth in terms of how
如果你过着这样的生活，你最终会积聚起那种助长许多此类行为的怨恨。所以在某种程度上，人们是在说，你知道，我觉得我不重要，但我会向你证明，实际上我很重要，而且我会在枪口下做到这一点。是的，完全如此。这就像你要说，好吧，你知道吗，我真的很重要。你们这些家伙以前看错我了，你们会得到一件让你们永远记住的东西。这太可悲了，你知道，与这个人毫无关系的无辜生命在这个过程中丧生了。这恰恰向你
you feel you're regarded or disregarded or unregarded by other people. You say that once a sense of non-mattering is in place, there are several factors that can make that condition worse, and one of those is perfectionism. Why would there be a connection between perfectionism and a feeling of not mattering? The bottom line is there's many thousands, millions of people who have this notion of, well, if I am perfect, I will matter to those people. But it's a very conditional sense of mattering. It's like, I have to be perfect in order to get the love, the respect, the attention, the interest. And unfortunately, my colleague has told me that he's had some famous people that he's spoken to as his private practice. And he says, these are people with remarkable achievements.
展示了重要感是多么的个人化。我说，你知道，它是可塑的，但它也是非常非常个人化的。它不等于归属感。归属感是指你在餐桌上有个位置。我说重要感是，当你在那张桌子上时，他们会听到你的声音吗，还是他们无视你并在那张桌子上抢着说话？所以它不等于归属感。它不等于社会支持。它是关于你觉得别人如何看待你、忽视你或不屑一顾的内在价值核心。你说一旦不重要感形成，有几个因素会使这种情况恶化，其中之一就是完美主义。为什么完美主义与不重要感之间会存在联系？归根结底，有成千上万、数以百万计的人持有这种观念：如果我表现完美，我对那些人来说就会很重要。但这是一种非常附带条件的重要感。就像是：我必须表现完美，才能获得爱、尊重、关注和兴趣。不幸的是，我的同事告诉我，他在自己的私人诊所里交谈过一些名人。他说，这些人取得了非凡的成就。
And then they learn, wait a minute, I've done this remarkable achievement, but it didn't matter. Like, I'm still being treated this way. And I remember the story of Marvin Gaye. And he, of course, was a famous singer with all kinds of hits, sexual he. hearing, heard it through the grapevine, and an icon to many. And unfortunately, what happened with him was eventually got into a dispute and was shot by his father. And Marvin had a situation. I remember a story whereby he had one of his hit singles. It could have been, I heard it through the grapevine. And he came to his dad, and he had something like 50,000 in cash. And he put the cash on the bed,
然后他们就会明白，等一下，我取得了如此卓越的成就，但这根本无济于事。就像我依然受到这种对待。我还记得马文·盖伊的故事。当然，他是一位著名的歌手，有很多热门歌曲，比如《Sexual Healing》、《I Heard It Through the Grapevine》，也是许多人心目中的偶像。但不幸的是，他后来卷入了一场争端，被他的父亲枪杀。马文曾遇到过这样一件事。我记得有一个故事，当时他有一首热门单曲。很可能是《I Heard It Through the Grapevine》。他去找他父亲，带了大约 5 万美元的现金。他把现金放在床上，
and he said to his dad, okay, now are you impressed with me? Now did I do something right? And his father's response with something along the lines of, all that matters is how you're viewed by the Lord. No, that money doesn't do it for me. It's how you're regarded in terms of the impossible standards of some higher being that's judging you, which is the essence of what we call socially prescribed perfectionism. So there you have a case of, you know, now do I matter? I've done this. Nobody else has done this. I've got the hit song everywhere, and it still wasn't enough. And this is what sadly happens with some people who are trying to strive for significance through being perfect. They discover that the interpersonal issues are still there. They're not
然后他对父亲说，好吧，现在你对我印象深刻了吗？现在我做对什么了吗？他父亲的回答大致意思是，唯一重要的是你在主眼中的看法。不，这些钱对我不起作用。重要的是你在某个评判你的至高无上的存在那里的标准下被如何看待，这正是我们所说的社会规定完美主义的本质。所以这就是一个例子，你懂的，我现在重要吗？我做到了这一点。没有其他人做到这一点。到处都是我的热门歌曲，但这依然不够。而这正是某些人试图通过追求完美来寻找存在感时，可悲的结局。他们发现人际关系的问题依然存在。他们并没有
getting that sense of importance, that sense of love and attention that they absolutely covet. And it's very sad that many famous people still have the problems of not feeling great about themselves due to that unmet need to matter. I can also imagine then if people are measuring themselves up to these impossible yardsticks, that a lot of what they're doing then is comparing themselves to other people? Yes, there's an incredible amount of comparison that goes on, and it's really destructive. There's no way to win the comparison game, especially now when people are putting crafted images of perfect lives online that are not actually real. But I do remember, in terms of social comparison, the best example I can give of somebody who was a perfectionist who
得到那种他们极为渴望的重要感、爱和关注。非常可悲的是，许多名人由于这种未得到满足的存在感需求，仍然面临着对自己感觉不佳的问题。我也可以想象，如果人们用这些不可能达到的标准来衡量自己，那么他们所做的事很大一部分是在与他人进行比较？是的，其中存在着大量的比较，而且这真的具有毁灭性。在比较游戏中根本没有赢的办法，尤其是现在，人们在网上展示精心修饰的完美生活图像，而这些实际上并不是真实的。但我确实记得，就社会比较而言，我可以给出的最好的一个例子，就是一位曾经是完美主义者的已故伟大人物
compare too much was the late great Brian Wilson, who just recently passed away, who suffered. from extreme mental health problems that became well known to everyone. And he was comparing himself to the Beatles and driving himself to the point of right over the edge. And at one point he said that he couldn't keep up with the Beatles. The Beach Boys, of course, were remarkable in their own right, but he needed to try and keep up with the Beatles in the heydays of Beetlemania. Yet this is Brian Wilson, who becomes famous and has entertained people around the world and will continue to even as his legacy.
过度比较了自己，也就是最近刚刚去世的已故伟大音乐家布赖恩·威尔逊，他遭受了众所周知的极端心理健康问题的折磨。他把自己和披头士乐队作比较，把自己逼到了崩溃的边缘。他曾一度表示，他无法跟上披头士乐队的步伐。当然，海滩男孩乐队本身也非常出色，但在披头士狂热的全盛时期，他需要努力跟上披头士乐队的脚步。然而这就是布赖恩·威尔逊，他成名了，为世界各地的人们带来了娱乐，并且作为他的传奇，这也将持续下去。
But he was torturing himself through these comparisons. And the lesson to people listening will be there's no way to win the comparison game, even if you're somebody as famous Brian Wilson, because you can always find a way. Yeah, I mean, there's always going to be someone who has done something more than you, better than you, faster than you, is richer than you? You know, how do you get out of that? Yeah, I've heard Olympic champions talk about how they're frustrated because if they'd only not made a mistake, including some of our own Canadian champions,
但他却通过这些比较在折磨自己。给听众的教训将是，在比较游戏中没有获胜的可能，即使你是像布赖恩·威尔逊这样有名的人，因为你总能找到办法。是的，我的意思是，总会有人做得比你多、比你好、比你快，比你有钱？你知道，你如何摆脱这种状态？是的，我听过奥运冠军谈论他们的沮丧，因为如果他们当初没有犯错的话，包括我们自己的一些加拿大冠军，
nobody would have beat that record for a longer time. Yet, you know, you did it. You won the gold medal. Donovan Bailey talked about the mistake he made coming out of the blocks as he set the world record and won the gold medal in the Atlanta Olympics. And later he's thinking about the mistake that he made because he could have gone faster. And then his record would have been protected longer.
就没有人能更长时间地打破那个纪录。然而，你知道，你做到了。你赢得了金牌。多纳文·贝利谈到他在亚特兰大奥运会上创造世界纪录并夺得金牌时，起跑时犯下的错误。后来他还在想着自己犯下的错误，因为他本可以跑得更快。那样的话，他的纪录就能保持更长时间了。
Talk about how this feeling of antimattering is related to how we can become trapped in these cycles of rumination. In some ways, you're hinting at this already. someone has accomplished something extraordinary, you know, winning a gold medal at the Olympics, breaking a world record is caught up in their own heads with what they haven't done instead of what they have done. Yeah. And I think not only are they caught up in terms of ruminating about mistakes and falling short, I believe they also ruminate and brood over interactions where people have made them feel like they don't matter. And what happens is that that then is a bridge
谈谈这种“毫无存在感”的感觉是如何与我们如何陷入这些反刍思维的循环中相关的。在某种程度上，你已经在暗示这一点了。某人取得了非凡的成就，你知道，在奥运会上赢得金牌、打破世界纪录，却在自己的脑海中纠结于他们没有做过的事，而不是他们已经做过的事。是的。而且我认为，他们不仅陷入了对错误和不足的反刍思考中，我相信他们还会反刍和盘算那些让他们觉得自己没有存在感的互动。而发生的情况是，这随后就成为了一座桥梁
to depression. So imagine if you're feeling depressed and then you're also ruminating about why you're feeling depressed, and then you're ruminating and thinking over and over about why aren't people seeing me and treating me as more significant, and why is my friend so significant and I'm not? What is it about me? And then people unfortunately conclude, well, they must be defective. They must have some shortcoming that, and they're just getting treated the way they deserve to be treated when, in fact, they don't deserve to be treated that way. among people who are struggling with life's challenges and also among those who seem to navigate those challenges with ease
通往抑郁。所以想象一下，如果你感到抑郁，然后你又在反刍为什么自己会感到抑郁，然后你又一遍又一遍地反刍和思考，为什么人们看不到我、不把我当成更重要的人看待，为什么我的朋友那么重要而我不是？我到底怎么了？然后人们不幸地得出结论，认为自己一定是有缺陷的。他们一定有什么缺点，他们只是受到了他们应得的待遇，而事实上，他们根本不该受到这种待遇。在那些与生活挑战作斗争的人当中，以及在那些似乎能轻而易举应对这些挑战的人当中
there may be a shared source spot the sense that at the end of the day they don't really matter the good news is that a sense of mattering can be consciously cultivated in ourselves and others when we come back how we can foster a sense of being seen heard and valued for who we are You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
可能存在一个共同的痛点：那就是在一天结束时，他们其实并不重要。好消息是，存在感可以在我们自己和他人身上被有意识地培养。当我们回来时，我们将探讨如何培养一种因我们本来的样子而被看见、被倾听和被重视的感觉。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Have you experienced a moment in your life when you felt profoundly invisible? Have you found a way to not feel invisible or to help others feel seen? If you have a story or a question you would like to share with the Hidden Brain audience,
这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。你的生活中是否曾经历过这样一刻：你感到自己彻底隐形了？你是否找到了某种方法，让自己不再感到隐形，或者帮助其他人感受到被看见？如果你有一个故事或问题想要与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享，
please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email it to us at feedback at hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, invisible. The drive to feel like we matter is deeply woven into the human psyche. Gorton Flett is the author of the psychology of mattering, understanding the human need to be significant.
请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将其发送至我们的邮箱 feedback@hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请标明：Invisible（隐形）。渴望觉得自己重要，深深地编织在人类的心理中。戈顿·弗莱特是《存在感的心理学：理解人类对重要性的需求》一书的作者。
Gord, you say that a feeling of mattering can be deliberately cultivated. Are you saying in some ways that we don't have to wait for the world to make us feel like we matter? we can start to do it ourselves? Yes, that's a great thing about it. We can get a sense of agency and a sense of importance by engaging in a pursuit of making other people feel better,
戈德，你说存在感是可以刻意培养的。你是在某种程度上说，我们不必等待世界让我们觉得自己重要？我们可以开始自己做到这一点吗？是的，这就是这件很棒的事情。我们可以通过参与让其他人感觉更好的追求，来获得一种自主感和重要感，
making a difference. I saw this with my wife's uncle who almost lived to 100. He lived by himself in the house he was born with by himself for almost 100 years. And, you know, he became the incredible volunteer
带来改变。我在我妻子的叔叔身上看到了这一点，他差一点活到100岁。他独自一人住在自己出生的房子里，独自生活了近100年。而且，你知道，他成为了社区里不可思议的志愿者
to his community. He would actually deliver meals on wheels, on wheels to people who were younger than him, and he would cackle when he'd tell me this. I'm in my 90s, and I'm giving help to people who are younger than me. He was also the church organist for over 80 years, because it was right around the corner, the church from his home. And I said to him one time, Derek, Uncle Derek, I said, how on earth have you got by? Have you ever had experience of loneliness?
他实际上会给那些比他年轻的人送“送餐上门”的餐食，当他跟我说起这个时，他会咯咯地笑。我都90多岁了，还在给比我年轻的人提供帮助。他还担任了80多年的教堂管风琴手，因为教堂离他家只有几个街角。有一次我对他说，德里克，德里克叔叔，我说，你到底是怎么熬过来的？你曾经体验过孤独吗？
And he cut me off, and he goes, not even for a second. He goes, because I know there are people in my community who care about me, but also rely and depend on me, which is a key part of feeling of mattering is that you can satisfy your sense of mattering by getting people who come to depend on you through coaching, mentoring, just being that person who reaches out to them when you're worrying about this, and then it comes back to you. So it's sort of like an investment where you're investing in your own sense of well-being by doing that and establishing those relationships with people who care about you, and it's the best kind of mattering is reciprocal mattering.
他打断了我的话，说道，一秒钟都没有。他说，因为我知道我的社区里有人关心我，但也依赖我、指望我，这是存在感的关键部分，你可以通过让那些开始依赖你的人来满足你的存在感，通过指导、当导师，或者仅仅成为那个在你担心时向他们伸出援手的人，然后这会回报给你。所以这有点像一项投资，你通过这样做来投资于自己的幸福感，并与那些关心你的人建立这些关系，这是最好的存在感，也就是相互的存在感。
you matter to each other. You say that one way we can begin to foster a sense of mattering is to reflect on all the ways in which we are already making an impact on the people around us. Say more about this idea, court. Yes, people, I think, forget what they've done for other people. They just lose sight of how much difference they've made in the lives of other people. You know, they say everybody at some time has dark thoughts,
你们对彼此都很重要。你说，我们开始培养存在感的一种方法，是反思我们已经在哪些方面对周围的人产生了影响。请多谈谈这个想法，戈德。是的，人们，我认为，会忘记他们为其他人做过的事。他们只是忽略了自己在其他人生活中产生了多大的影响。你知道，他们说每个人在某个时候都会有黑暗的想法，
but, you know, at that point, that would be a great time to think about somebody who you've made a difference to. who would miss you. So when we talk about in psychology about mindfulness, I say we need to be mindful about mattering and mattering mindfulness where we say, okay, not just in the here and now, but how have we thought about ourselves
但是，你知道，在那种时刻，那将是思考一个你曾对其产生过影响、会想念你的人的绝佳时机。所以当我们在心理学中谈论正念时，我说我们需要对存在感保持正念，也就是“存在感正念”，我们说，好吧，不仅是在此时此地，我们如何看待自己
in terms of making a difference to other people? I want to spend a moment talking about how and why we lose track of what we have actually done for others and how we actually do matter to others. I want to play you a clip from the 1995 film, Mr. Holland's opus. In that movie, Richard Dreyfus plays a music teacher
对其他人产生影响的角度？我想花一点时间和大家谈谈，我们是如何以及为什么会忘记我们实际上为他人做了什么，以及我们如何切实地对他人产生重要影响。我想放一段1995年电影《生命中不可承受之情》（Mr. Holland's Opus）中的片段。在这部电影中，理查德·德莱福斯饰演一位音乐老师
who is determined to write a great symphony. He struggles to achieve this lofty goal and toward the end of his life, he feels like he has failed. At a gathering to commemorate his retirement, a former student of his takes the podium, and here's the clip of what the student tells him. Mr. Holland had a profound influence on my life,
他决心写一部伟大的交响曲。他为实现这一崇高的目标而挣扎，在生命快结束时，他觉得自己失败了。在纪念他退休的聚会上，他的一位前学生走上讲台，以下是学生对他说的话的片段。霍兰先生对我的生活产生了深远的影响，
on a lot of lives, I know. And yet I get the feeling that he considers a great part of his own life misspent. Rumor had it, he was always working on this symphony of his, and this was going to make him famous, rich, probably both. But Mr. Holland isn't rich, and he isn't famous, at least not outside of our little town. So it might be easy for him to think himself a failure.
我知道，对很多人的生活也是如此。然而我有一种感觉，他认为自己生活很大一部分都被浪费了。有传言说，他一直在创作他的这部交响曲，这会让他成名、发财，或者两者兼得。但霍兰先生既没有发财，也没有成名，至少在我们这个小镇之外没有。所以他很容易认为自己是个失败者。
and he would be wrong because I think he's achieved a success far beyond riches and fain look around you there is not a life in this room that you have not touched and each one of us is a better person because of you
而他错了，因为我认为他取得了远超财富和名誉的成功。环顾四周，这个房间里没有哪一个生活是你没有触动过的，我们每个人都因为你而成为了更好的人
we are your symphony Mr. Holland we are the melodies and the notes of your opus and we are the music of your life. What do you hear in that clip, Gord? What's going on? Mattering is so subjective where people can very easily lose sight of having an impact on others that they don't realize. This is quite common with teachers where they don't realize,
我们就是你的交响曲，霍兰先生，我们是你宏大作品中的旋律和音符，我们是你生命的音乐。戈德，你在那个片段里听到了什么？发生了什么？存在感是如此主观，以至于人们很容易忽视自己对他人产生的、他们自己并未意识到影响。这在老师中很常见，他们没有意识到，
they get frustrated, maybe focused on the one student who doesn't seem to be getting it rather than all the ones who are getting it. And a key thing is that mattering is subjective, that it's our appraisals of how we think, you know, do we matter to, others are others holding us in esteem. That's why it's very important to show somebody they matter in a way so it's not subjective. And in the clip, of course, the famous clip of that student is the governor who's come back now to be part of the band to play Mr. Holland's opus that he never got to have. And, you know, I said, how wonderful it would be for everybody who's facing a job transition, whether it's retirement or whatever, to have people come and just express their appreciation.
他们会感到沮丧，也许只专注于那个似乎没有理解的学生，而不是所有那些已经理解了的学生。关键的一点是，存在感是主观的，它是我们对自己想法的评估，你知道，我们在其他人眼中重要吗？其他人是否对我们抱有敬意？这就是为什么以一种不那么主观的方式向某人展示他们很重要是非常重要的。而在那个片段中，当然，那个学生的著名片段是那个现在回来成为乐队成员、来演奏霍兰先生从未能拥有的那部宏大作品的州长。而且，你知道，我说过，对于每个面临职业转型的人来说，无论是退休还是其他什么，有这样一群人来表达他们的感激之情，将是多么美妙的事。
and just tell a very quick story. So I mentioned this at a conference just back in the fall of last year. And in the question period, a teacher put up her hand in educator, and she said this notion of not being able to see what effect you've had on others. She goes, I was recently contacted by a parole officer of a former student who said that the student provided her name as somebody to contact to essentially a character reference. And she said, I remember the student as a character reference. And she said, I remember the student as being someone who I thought I just didn't get through to.
并且只讲一个非常简短的故事。所以我去年秋天在一个会议上提到了这一点。在问答环节，一位女教师、一位教育工作者举起了手，她说了这个无法看到自己对他人产生何种影响的概念。她说，我最近接到了一位前学生假释官的电话，假释官说该学生提供了她的名字作为联系人，本质上是作为品行证明人。她说，我记得这个学生作为一个品行证明人。她说，我记得这个学生是我认为我根本无法触及的人。
But when asked, he said that he's giving her name because she is the only one who saw him for what he was, who really gave him a sense of being valued and cared about. Yet she, until that point, had not realized that she actually had that kind of an impact on the young man. So we're often not a good judge of how much impact we have of others, which makes that sense of not mattering or not sure of your matting very, very good. insidious and potentially destructive. And I've seen cases where I say, you know, it's too bad. The person never realized how much regard others had for him or her or they.
但当被问及时，他说他给出了她的名字，因为她是唯一一个看清他本色的人，真正给了他一种被重视和被关怀的感觉。然而在此之前，她并没有意识到自己竟然对这个年轻男子产生了那种影响。所以我们往往不是衡量我们对他人影响力的好裁判，这使得那种觉得没有存在感或不确定自己是否存在感的感觉变得非常非常隐蔽且具有潜在的破坏力。我见过一些案例，我说，你知道，真遗憾，这个人从来没有意识到其他人对他、她或他们有多么高的敬意。
One of the things that has come up in this conversation that I think is worth flagging here is that, you know, mattering might be more a matter of quality rather than quantity. And what I mean by that is you don't need necessarily, you know, five billion people to think that you're great for you to have your psychological needs met, you might need one person, you might need two people. And this speaks to the story you just told me. This guy is in trouble. He's basically speaking to a parole officer, and he's referring the parole officer to someone who was in his very distant past, because that's the person his mind gravitates toward. Yeah, yeah. It's such an excellent and underscored point that, you know, the quality of the
这次对话中出现的一点，我认为在这里值得指出的是，你知道，存在感可能更多是关于质量而不是数量的问题。我的意思是，你不需要一定有50亿人认为你很棒，你的心理需求才能得到满足，你可能只需要一个人，你可能需要两个人。这呼应了你刚才给我讲的故事。这家伙遇到了麻烦。他基本上是在跟假释官谈话，而他把假释官引荐给了一个在他非常遥远的过去的人，因为那是他脑海中最自然倾向的人。是的，是的。这是一个如此精彩且被强调的观点，你知道，关系质量，那种感觉，有人真正关心你，你知道
relationships, the quality, that sense of somebody truly caring and you know. they care and they're not going to forget you is a huge thing here. And, you know, in terms of that one-to-one relationship, I always come back to the famous book by Mitch Albem Tuesdays with Mori. And referring to a former professor as coach and going to see him right through to his final days due to his illness as he's approaching the end of his life, that's, I think, what made that book so famous is that people could relate to that basic feeling of having somebody who cares that much about you. And nobody can take that kind of a relationship away and nobody can take that kind of feeling away from you. You say that it's also possible for us to intentionally set out
他们关心你，而且不会忘记你，这是一个巨大的事情。而且，你知道，就那种一对一的关系而言，我总是会想起米奇·阿尔姆的著名书作《相约星期二》（Tuesdays with Morrie）。把一位前教授称为教练，并在他因病接近生命尽头的最后日子里一直去探望他，我认为，这就是那本书如此著名的原因，因为人们能够对那种“拥有一个如此深切关心你的人”的基本感觉产生共鸣。没有人能夺走那种关系，也没有人能从你身上夺走那种感觉。你说，我们也有可能刻意出发
to make others in our lives feel like they matter. If we are parents or teachers, for example, we can engage in what you call micro practices that promote mattering in children. What are these practices. Yeah, that focus in part comes from the school that's just two blocks away from where we live here, where it was an incredible, I want to call a mattering milieu, because the principal, Peggy Morrison knew, even though there was almost 1,000 children in the school, knew every child by name, would go up and talk to them at, well, waiting to go into school or at recess, could mention a brother or a sister, something that was important to them. So it's partly, you know, acknowledging somebody, showing them,
让我们生活中的其他人觉得他们很重要。例如，如果我们是父母或老师，我们可以从事你所说的在儿童中促进存在感的微观实践。这些实践是什么？是的，这部分的关注点来自于离我们在这里居住的地方仅仅两个街区远的那所学校，那是一个令人难以置信的，我想称之为“存在感环境”的地方，因为校长佩奇·莫里森知道，尽管学校里将近有1000名儿童，但她知道每个孩子的名字，会在他们等待进学校时或在课间休息时走过去和他们交谈，能提到他们的兄弟或姐妹，或者对他们来说重要的事情。所以这在某种程度上，你知道，是承认某人，向他们展示
personal attention, knowing and remembering something about them. If they've been away for a while, tell them that they've been missed. Peggy Morrison is also the master of the lost art of writing a personal note to somebody. Bottom line is when you give attention to somebody and more importantly, you give time to someone, you're locked on to them in a way that they can feel unmistakably that they matter. So in addition to our role as parents and teachers, you say that as leaders of all kinds, as managers or coaches, we can help others feel like they matter. And you tell a story about the famous football coach, Vince Lombardi. Tell me that story. This is a story that's in a book by Jerry Kramer, one of the offensive linemen who grew up to be one of the stars and became a member of the Football Hall of Fame.
个人关注，了解并记住关于他们的某些事情。如果他们离开了一段时间，告诉他们大家想念他们。佩奇·莫里森也是写私人便条这项失传艺术的大师。底线是，当你给予某人关注，更重要的是，当你给予某人时间时，你以一种让他们明确无误地感受到自己很重要的方式锁定了他们。因此，除了我们作为父母和老师的角色外，你说，作为各种领导者、管理者或教练，我们可以帮助其他人觉得他们很重要。你讲了一个关于著名美式橄榄球教练文斯·隆巴迪的故事。跟我讲讲那个故事。这是一个收录在杰里·克雷默书中的故事，杰里·克雷默是那些成长为球星并成为美式橄榄球名人堂成员的进攻锋线队员之一。
and Kramer made a horrible mistake where he let the guy go by him, and the star quarterback, Bart Starr, he was hit so hard, they wondered if he was going to be able to play from that point on. So on Monday practice came along. They have film session, and Vince Lombardi, the famous coach, put Kramer right at the front, and then he showed the video of Kramer blowing the block that almost killed the star quarterback about 30 times.
而克雷默犯了一个可怕的错误，他让防守球员从他身边溜了过去，明星四分卫巴特·斯塔尔被撞得如此之重，以至于人们怀疑他从那以后还能不能打球。于是周一的训练开始了。他们有看录像的环节，著名的教练文斯·隆巴迪把克雷默直接安排在最前面，然后把克雷默漏掉那个差点害死明星四分卫的阻挡的录像放了大约30遍。
And it got to the point where Kramer said, I guess this is my last day with the Green Bay Packers, I'll be clearing my stuff out of my locker because why is the coach doing this humiliating me with all the teammates there? So he's sitting there, flash forward, he's sitting at his locker, thinking maybe it's time to start clearing this locker out. And an arm comes around him when nobody's there. And it's Vince Lombardi, who says to Kramer, you're probably wondering why I did that to you. He goes, I know that you have greatness in you. And you'll never make that mistake again. You say that as people going about our lives, we have endless opportunities to offer a sense of mattering to the people we meet.
以至于克雷默说，我想这是我在绿湾包装工队的最后一天了，我要把我的东西从储物柜里清出去了，因为教练为什么要这样做，在所有队友面前羞辱我？所以他就坐在那里，镜头快进，他坐在自己的储物柜前，想着也许是时候开始把这个储物柜清空了。这时一只胳膊环住了他，当时周围没有别人。那是文斯·隆巴迪，他对克雷默说，你可能在想我为什么要那样对你。他说，我知道你身上有伟大的潜质。而且你绝不会再犯那个错误了。你说，作为生活中的人们，我们有无尽的机会向我们遇到的人提供存在感。
I understand that your brother once met a very famous person who took the time to make him feel like he mattered. Tell me that story. It's a story of my brother, Glenn, my youngest brother. And he decided to become a photographer's assistant as his hobby. And one time he told me that they had an event in Hamilton, Ontario, and it involved taking photos of President Bill Clinton. And he's helping out, and there's the famous guy, and all the Secret Service guys are there, and women. And at the end, when they're wrapping up, he gets a tap on his shoulder, and he turns around, and it's Bill Clinton. And Bill Clinton says to him,
我听说你的哥哥曾经遇到过一个非常有名的人，那个人花时间让他觉得他很重要。给我讲讲那个故事。这是一个关于我哥哥格伦的故事，我最小的哥哥。他决定把摄影师助理当成他的业余爱好。有一次他告诉我，他们在安大略省汉密尔顿市有一个活动，其中涉及拍摄美国总统比尔·克林顿的照片。他在帮忙，那个大人物也在，所有的特勤局特工和女性特工都在那里。最后，当他们结束工作准备收工时，他的肩膀被人拍了一下，他转过身，发现是比尔·克林顿。比尔·克林顿对他说，
you've heard my story. Tell me about you. What's going on with you? And I thought, that's amazing. And people talk about what charisma is. I think sometimes charisma is that you're just generally interested in people. It's not fake. It's not phony. And, you know, that made all the difference in the world to my brother who I have a feeling at times that not felt that way in terms of being significant. Gordon Flett is a psychologist at York University in Canada. He's the author of The Psychology of Mattering, Understanding the Human Need to Be Significant. Gort, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Thank you. Have you experienced a moment in your life when you felt profoundly invisible?
你听过我的故事了。跟我讲讲你吧。你最近怎么样？我当时想，这太棒了。人们谈论什么是个人魅力。我认为有时个人魅力就是你对人普遍感兴趣。它不是虚假的。它不是伪装的。而且，你知道，这对我哥哥来说产生了巨大的改变，我有时觉得他在重要感方面并没有那种感受。戈登·弗莱特是加拿大约克大学的心理学家。他是《存在感的心理学：理解人类对重要性的需求》一书的作者。戈德，非常感谢你今天来到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你。你的生活中是否曾经历过这样一刻：你感到自己彻底隐形了？
Have you found a way to not feel invisible or to help others feel seen? If you have a story or a question you would like to share with the Hidden Brain audience, please find a very quiet room and record a voice memo on your phone. Two or three minutes is plenty. Email it to us at Feedback at Hiddenbrain.org. Use the subject line, Invisible. When we come back, remarkable story. about the healing power of nature.
你是否找到了某种方法，让自己不再感到隐形，或者帮助其他人感受到被看见？如果你有一个故事或问题想要与《隐藏的大脑》的听众分享，请找一个非常安静的房间，在手机上录一段语音备忘录。两三分钟就足够了。将其发送至我们的邮箱 Feedback@hiddenbrain.org。邮件主题请标明：Invisible（隐形）。当我们回来时，将是一个关于自然治愈力量的非凡故事。
I saw the fall leaves, the oranges and reds and yellows and shades of brown, and it was just so gorgeous. And I just said to myself, that's what I'm going to live for, and that is enough. The beauty of the fall leaves is enough. The psychologist Mark Berman returns to the show to answer listener questions about our relationship to the Great Outdoors. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Some time ago, we invited listeners to share stories about their experiences with nature.
我看到了秋天的树叶，橙色、红色、黄色和各种深浅不一的棕色，真的是太美了。我当时就对自己说，这就是我要为什么而活，这就够了。秋叶的美丽就已经够了。心理学家马克·伯曼重返节目，回答听众关于我们与大自然关系的提问。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。一段时间以前，我们邀请听众分享他们在大自然中的经历故事。
One person who responded was a woman named Stephanie. She told us about a time when she was 18 and got into a serious car crash. Stephanie was driving and her boyfriend was in the passenger seat. They were both flung from the car. Stephanie broke five vertebrae in her back, but recovered from her injuries. Her boyfriend was paralyzed, his neck was broken. And although it was an accident and it was probably unavoidable, I felt entirely responsible for that outcome,
做出回应的人中有一位名叫斯蒂芬妮的女士。她给我们讲述了她18岁时遭遇严重车祸的一次经历。当时斯蒂芬妮在开车，她的男朋友坐在副驾驶座上。他们俩都被从车里甩了出去。斯蒂芬妮的背部有五节脊椎骨骨折，但伤势恢复了。她的男朋友瘫痪了，他的脖子断了。尽管这是一场事故，而且可能是不可避免的，但我对那个结果感到完全的责任，
and I just felt worthless as a human being. I didn't want to live anymore. I just didn't feel that I brought any value to the world. and I was just desperately looking for something to live for. Some time later, Stephanie found herself in a cafe. It was autumn in the Midwest. The leaves were changing color on the trees outside the cafe. She looked at them as she drank her coffee.
我当时觉得自己作为一个活生生的人毫无价值。我不想再活下去了。我只是觉得自己没有为世界带来任何价值，我当时在拼命地寻找活下去的理由。一段时间后，斯蒂芬妮发现自己坐在一家咖啡馆里。那是中西部地区的秋天。咖啡馆外树上的叶子正在变色。她一边喝着咖啡一边看着它们。
And I saw the oranges and reds and yellows and shades of brown, and it was just so gorgeous. And I just said to myself, that's what I'm going to live for, and that is enough. The beauty of the fall leaves is enough. And now I'm 57, and I've had a great life, and I'm so glad that nature really saved my life. Many of us will experience losses and setbacks.
我看到了橙色、红色、黄色和各种深浅不一的棕色，真的是太美了。我当时就对自己说，这就是我要为什么而活，这就够了。秋叶的美丽就已经够了。现在我57岁了，我度过了美好的一生，我非常高兴大自然真的拯救了我的生命。我们中的许多人都将经历失去和挫折。
We'll say goodbye to people we adore and to jobs we love. We'll face illness and injury. One thing many of us forget during such times is the solace offered by the natural world. At the University of Chicago, Mark Berman studies our relationship to nature. He joined us some time ago on an episode titled How Nature Heels Us. If you missed it, you can find that episode in this podcast feed or at hiddenbrain.org. Today, Mark returns to the show to respond to some of the hundreds of stories and questions we received.
我们会向我们深爱的人和热爱的工作告别。我们要面对疾病和伤痛。在我们经历这些时刻时，许多人忘记的一件事，就是自然世界所提供的慰藉。在芝加哥大学，马克·伯曼研究我们与自然的关系。不久前他曾做客我们的一期节目，题目是《自然如何治愈我们》。如果你错过了，你可以在这个播客动态中或在 hiddenbrain.org 上找到那期节目。今天，马克重返节目，回应我们收到的成百上千个故事和提问。
Mark Berman, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you again for having me. Mark, many listeners wrote in to share the benefits that nature has had on their minds. Can you remind us of what the research is found about how nature affects us psychologically and emotionally? Yeah, and a lot of the research that we've done and other people have done has looked at how interacting with nature can improve your attention or your ability to focus. And people also find that interacting with nature just makes people feel better, that it can improve your mood, that it can kind of even make you feel more connected to the rest of the world.
马克·伯曼，欢迎再次来到《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢再次邀请我。马克，许多听众写信分享大自然对他们的心灵产生的好处。你能提醒我们，关于自然如何从心理和情感上影响我们，研究都发现了什么吗？是的，我们和其他人做过的大量研究都探讨了与自然的互动如何能够改善你的注意力或专注能力。人们还发现，与自然的互动只会让人感觉更好，它能够改善你的情绪，甚至能让你在某种程度上感觉自己与世界其余部分联系得更紧密。
And so many researchers, including researchers in my lab, have found that interactions with nature can also make you feel more connected to other people, more connected to the physical environment, and also kind of helps to make you more reflective in your thoughts. So there's just a multitude of benefits to interacting with nature. I think the most common theme we heard from listeners is that nature helps them calm down when they're feeling anxious or overwhelmed. We heard from a listener named Jennifer who says that when she's stressed out, she visits the bees who love the flowers in her backyard. I've never been stung and I just listen to the buzzing and feel them around my face and arms. And they really, really calm my heartbeat. they calm my nerves. And when I'm done commuting with the bees,
所以许多研究人员，包括我实验室的研究人员发现，与自然的互动还可以让你感觉与其他人联系得更紧密，与物理环境联系得更紧密，并且在某种程度上也有助于让你在思考时更具反思性。因此，与大自然互动有着诸多好处。我认为我们从听众那里听到最普遍的主题是，当他们感到焦虑或不知所措时，大自然能帮助他们平静下来。我们听到一位名叫詹妮弗的听众说，当她压力很大时，她会去拜访那些喜欢她后院花朵的蜜蜂。我从来没有被蛰过，我只是听着嗡嗡声，感受它们在我的脸和手臂周围飞舞。它们真的、真的能让我的心跳平静下来，它们能安抚我的神经。当我与蜜蜂的交流结束时，
I always tell them, thank you. And then I go back inside. And I just have this sense of peace and calm that only bees can bring. So, Mark, there were a series of studies done in the 1980s and 90s that looked at how nature can affect us when we are feeling stressed out.
我总是对它们说，谢谢你们。然后我走回室内。我就拥有了一种只有蜜蜂才能带来的平和与平静的感觉。所以，马克，在20世纪80和90年代进行过一系列研究，探讨了当我们感到压力时，自然如何影响我们。
Those studies had a great influence on you. What did the research find? Yes, these were some really seminal studies done by Roger Ulrich. where Roger was really interested to see if interacting with nature could buffer people against stress. And what Roger did was he would show people some imagery that would cause people to feel kind of stressed, like looking at a picture of a knife that's about to cut somebody's finger. And Roger was then interested to see, okay, if after presenting people with these stressful images,
那些研究对你产生了很大的影响。研究发现了什么？是的，这些是罗杰·乌尔里希做的一些非常具有开创性的研究，罗杰当时非常想看看与大自然的互动是否能缓冲人们受到的压力。罗杰的做法是，他会向人们展示一些会导致人们感到某种压力的图像，比如看一张一把刀正要切到别人手指的照片。然后罗杰有兴趣看看，好吧，如果在向人们展示了这些有压力的图像之后，
if he then showed people pictures of nature or movies of nature versus pictures of more of an urban environment or urban movies, he found that people returned more to baseline stress levels faster after seeing the nature stimulation compared to the urban stimulation, suggesting that the natural stimulation could sort of de-stress people or even buffer them against stress. I'd like to circle back to something you mentioned earlier that spending time in nature can improve our attention. You've done some research on this, Mark. Tell me about that.
如果他接着向人们展示自然的图片或自然的电影，与展示更具城市环境的图片或城市电影相比，他发现，在看到自然刺激后，人们恢复到基准压力水平的速度比看到城市刺激后更快，这表明自然刺激可以在某种程度上消除人们的压力，甚至缓冲他们免受压力的影响。我想回到你之前提到的一点，即在大自然中度过时光可以改善我们的注意力。你对此做过一些研究，马克。跟我讲讲那个研究吧。
Yeah, absolutely. So we had done a study where we had participants, and we had them walk in nature one week or walk in an urban environment a second week. and what we found was interesting that when participants walked in nature, they showed about a 20% improvement in their ability to concentrate compared to a 50-minute walk in a more urban environment. And, you know, another interesting element to that study too was that participants didn't even need to like the nature interaction to get the benefit. So when we had people walk in June, when it was about 80 degrees Fahrenheit in Ann Arbor, Michigan,
好的，没问题。所以我们曾做过一项研究，让参与者在一周内在自然中散步，或者在第二周在一个城市环境中散步。而我们发现的结果很有意思，当参与者在自然中散步时，与在更具城市环境的环境中散步50分钟相比，他们的专注能力表现出了大约20%的提升。而且，你知道，那项研究中另一个有趣的元素是，参与者甚至不需要喜欢与自然的互动就能获得这种好处。所以当我们让人们在六月份去散步时，当时密歇根州安阿伯市的温度大约是华氏80度，
participants really enjoyed the walk and they showed really large attention benefits. But we also had some participants walk in January when it was about 25 degrees Fahrenheit and people did not like the walk in nature, but they showed the same attention improvement as the people that walked in June. So that was very interesting that you didn't have to necessarily like the nature walk to get the benefit. You also looked at how nature can affect our moods. a story about nature and depression from a listener named Betsy.
参与者真的很喜欢那次散步，并且他们表现出了非常巨大的注意力益处。但我们也让一些参与者在华氏25度左右的一月份去散步，人们并不喜欢在大自然中散步，但他们表现出了与六月份散步的人相同的注意力提升。所以这非常有趣，你并不一定非得喜欢自然散步才能获得这种好处。你们还研究了自然如何影响我们的情绪。请分享一个关于自然与抑郁的故事，来自一位名叫贝特的听众。
My daughter was diagnosed with cancer when she was five months old, and I fell into a really dark depression. But what I did every day, no matter the temperature, and I live in Minnesota, so it's pretty cold, is go for a walk outside. And I think that is one of the reasons I was able to get through such an impossibly difficult time. It helped me get back to the moment and stay outside of myself for moments of time
我的女儿在五个月大时被诊断出患有癌症，我陷入了非常黑暗的抑郁之中。但我每天都会做的一件事，无论气温如何——我住在明尼苏达州，所以天气相当冷——就是去户外散步。我认为这是我能够度过这样一个不可思议的困难时期的原因之一。它帮助我回到了当下，在一段时间里将自己抽离于内心深处，
instead of focusing on the scary future and scary present. I really, really am a huge advocate for nature and getting outside and walking. My daughter is now two years in remission, and my family tries to get out every day for that walk, no matter the weather. I'm so glad that Betsy's daughter is doing a, better, Mark, but one thing that struck me about what she said is that walking helps her get outside of herself for a period of time. Does nature help us see ourselves differently? Yes, and that's a very powerful story from Betsy, and again, too, I'm very happy that
而不是去关注可怕的未来和可怕的现在。我真的、真的是大自然以及去户外散步的坚定倡导者。我女儿现在已经缓解两年了，无论天气如何，我的家人都努力每天出去散步。我很高兴贝特的女儿情况好转了，马克，但关于她所说的话，有一点让我印象深刻，那就是散步帮助她有一段时间得以跳脱自我。大自然能帮助我们以不同的方式看待自己吗？是的，这是来自贝特的一个非常强有力的故事，同样，我也非常高兴
her daughter is in remission to, and yes, I think what Betsy's intuition is about being in nature can get you sort of maybe less thinking about yourself is something that we actually find. So we did some studies where we had people walk in an indoor nature conservatory in Chicago, the Garfield Conservatory, versus also interacting with a nice indoor space, the Water Tower Mall in Chicago. And a few things really struck us. So one is that in nature, people tended to think less about themselves and more about others, even though, you know, there might have been fewer or the same amount of people in the nature conservatory versus the mall.
她的女儿病情也得到了缓解，是的，我认为贝特关于置身于大自然中可以让你或许减少对自己的思考的直觉，正是我们实际发现的。所以我们做了一些研究，让人们在芝加哥的一个室内自然温室（加菲尔德温室）里散步，同时也在芝加哥的一个漂亮的室内空间（水塔广场购物中心）里进行互动。有几件事确实让我们印象深刻。其中之一就是，在大自然中，人们往往较少考虑自己，而更多地考虑他人，尽管，你知道，自然温室里的人数可能比购物中心里的人数少或相当。
So that was pretty interesting and also kind of consistent with what Betsy was saying. We also found that people's thoughts were more positive in nature. Their thoughts were a bit more creative. And they felt more connected to the larger world, which I think is also really interesting. So it does sort of seem like interacting with nature can sort of, sort of, of make people maybe be a little bit less egocentric and feel a little bit more connected to the physical world, but also to people around the world. It might help us to see each other as being a bit more human, which other studies have found too, that interactions with nature
所以这相当有趣，这也与贝特所说的一致。我们还发现，人们在大自然中的想法更加积极。他们的想法更有创造力。他们觉得与更大的世界的联系更加紧密，我认为这也是非常有趣的。因此，与大自然的互动确实在某种程度上似乎可以让人变得稍微没有那么自我中心，并感觉与物理世界以及世界各地的人们的联系更加紧密。它可能有助于我们将彼此视为更具人性的人，其他研究也发现，与大自然的互动
can actually make people to humanize other people rather than dehumanize other people. And I think it can make us feel more connected to the actual natural environment. And we know that, you know, with the problems with climate change and things like that, that it's going to be important for us as humans to strengthen our relationship to nature. We heard from many listeners who have dealt with the death of a loved one by seeking out nature. We can't play all of the messages we received, but let's hear two of them. Here are Anjali and Randy. My husband died at the age of 43.
实际上可以让人类化其他人，而不是将其他人非人化。而且我认为它能让我们感觉与实际的自然环境联系得更紧密。我们知道，随着气候变化等问题，对于我们人类来说，加强我们与自然的关系将是重要的。我们听到许多听众讲述了他们通过寻找大自然来应对亲人离世的经历。我们无法播放我们收到的所有留言，但让我们听听其中的两条。这里是安贾莉和兰迪。我的丈夫在43岁时去世了。
I was 37 with an almost two-year-old. And taking walks in nature, being at the beach, being in the woods, was transformational. My partner had just passed away after a difficult battle with Parkinson's and dementia. But instead of going directly to the house, I decided to go out to the open space desert just a few minutes away. There are these really big stones and boulders out there. I don't know how they got there. And I decided to just stand on one of them,
我37岁，带着一个快两岁的孩子。在大自然中散步，在海滩上，在树林里，是具有变革意义的。我的伴侣在与帕金森病和痴呆症进行了艰难的斗争后刚刚去世。但为了不直接回家，我决定去几分钟路程外的开阔沙漠空间。那里有这些非常大的石头和巨石。我不知道它们是怎么到那里的。我决定只站在其中一块上，
and I let it go, and I gave my grief to the earth, because I've always believed, as a Native American, that the earth heals you. So then I got down, and I literally just put my arms around that rock, and I just let it all out, and I cried and I sobbed and I said little prayers and found a way to comfort myself. As I got back into my car to go home finally, I noticed I did feel a little lighter, a little more grounded. Mark, these are such powerful and moving stories.
我放下了，我把我的悲伤交给了大地，因为我一直作为美洲原住民相信，大地会治愈你。于是我下来了，我字面意义上只是用双臂环抱住那块岩石，我把一切都宣泄出来，我哭泣、啜泣，做着小小的祈祷，找到了安慰自己的方法。当我终于回到车里准备回家时，我注意到我确实感觉轻松了一点，更脚踏实地了一点。马克，这些都是非常有力且感人的故事。
Has there been any research specifically on the effects that nature can have on people who are grieving? Yes, absolutely. Those are incredibly powerful stories. I appreciate the listeners for sending them. And yes, there has been work looking at how interacting with nature can help people when people are grieving. And when I was doing some research for my book, Nature and the Mind, I ran across some interesting stories of people who grieved in nature with something called a wind phone. And what a wind phone is, it's this big physical phone, but it doesn't have a line. It's not connected to anything. And people were putting these phones out in beautiful nature to use sort of metaphorically to talk to loved ones when they were out in nature. And I just found that to be really, really powerful. And when you're grieving, it's, it's, it's, It's not quite the same as clinical depression, but it sort of feels like clinical depression. And, you know, people are going to be ruminating
有没有专门针对大自然对处于悲痛中的人产生的影响的研究？是的，绝对有。这些故事具有不可思议的力量。我很感激听众们把它们发给我们。是的，确实有研究探讨当人们处于悲痛之中时，与大自然的互动如何能够帮助他们。当我在为我的书《大自然与心灵》（Nature and the Mind）做一些研究时，我偶然发现了一些有趣的故事：人们在自然中用一种叫做“风之电话”（wind phone）的东西来寄托哀思。风之电话是一个很大的实体电话，但它没有电话线。它没有连接到任何东西。人们把这些电话放在美丽的自然中，当他们在户外时，用它来作隐喻，与挚爱之人对话。我发现这真的、真的很震撼。当你感到悲伤时，它、它、它、它虽然不完全等同于临床抑郁症，但感觉有点像临床抑郁症。而且，你知道，人们会陷入沉思
and they're going to be very upset, not being able to talk to those loved ones. I mean, I went through a time period about 10 years ago when all three of my living grandparents died within six months of each other. And it was a very difficult time. and often when you're feeling such extreme grief or you're having really, really hard difficulties, it can be really, really beneficial to turn to nature.
他们会非常难过，无法与那些挚爱的人对话。我的意思是，大约10年前，我经历过一段时间，当时我的三位健在的祖父母在六个月内相继去世。那是一段非常艰难的时期。通常，当你感受到如此极致的悲伤，或者遇到非常、非常困难的险境时，转向大自然会是非常、非常有益的。
And so I did try myself to walk in nature in these times. And again, because we're all a part of nature. And as our research has shown, being in nature makes us feel more connected. It kind of can put things into perspective. and interactions with nature are not going to bring our loved ones back, but I think being out in nature can help us to feel more connected to those loved ones and more connected to the natural world. We're all part of the natural world,
所以在这些时候，我自己确实尝试过去大自然中散步。而且同样是因为我们都是大自然的一部分。正如我们的研究表明的那样，身处大自然能让我们感到更多的连结。它能在某种程度上把事情放在正确的视角来看待。与大自然的互动并不能让我们的挚爱死而复生，但我认为置身于大自然中可以帮助我们感到与这些挚爱有更深的连结，并与自然世界产生更紧密的连结。我们都是自然世界的一部分，
and unfortunately, death is part of the natural world. That we're all going to face that, and I think that nature can kind of help to give us that good perspective. When we come back, how are cultural views? shape our engagement with nature. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam.
而不幸的是，死亡也是自然世界的一部分。我们终将面对这一切，我认为大自然能在某种程度上帮我们建立这种良好的视角。稍后回来，文化观点是如何塑造我们与大自然的互动的？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》（Hidden Brain）。我是香卡·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vedantam）。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。
We have many idioms and metaphors about nature. Mother Earth, the tree of life, a river of time, branching possibilities. All of these suggest the many ways our experience of nature is woven into our experience of the world. Mark Berman is a psychologist
我们有很多关于大自然的习语和隐喻。大地母亲、生命之树、时间之河、分岔的可能性。所有这些都表明，我们对大自然的体验融入我们对世界的体验之中的多种方式。马克·伯曼（Mark Berman）是一名心理学家，
at the University of Chicago. He studies the effects that nature has on our minds. Mark, we talked about how nature can help us when we're depressed or stressed or grieving. We also heard from listeners with thoughts about our cultural and philosophical views on nature. One of those messages came from Lisa. She's from Canada, and she shared the perspective of her indigenous culture, the Métis people. The thing that we understand is that we're a part of nature. We're not separate from nature.
就职于芝加哥大学（University of Chicago）。他专门研究大自然对我们心灵的影响。马克，我们讨论过大自然如何在人们沮丧、压力大或悲伤时提供帮助。我们还听取了听众对我们关于大自然的文化和哲学观点的看法。其中一条信息来自丽莎（Lisa）。她来自加拿大，分享了她所在的土著文化——梅蒂人（Métis people）的视角。我们所理解的是，我们是大自然的一部分。我们并非与大自然分离。
And so when we are there surrounded by the water or the forest, that we feel, well, we feel at home. We understand that the forest, the water, the trees, that they're relatives to us. And so it's like being surrounded by family. It's very healing. What do you think of this framing, Mark? We often use the phrase, the natural world,
所以当我们身处其中，被水流或森林环绕时，我们会感到，嗯，我们有家的感觉。我们明白森林、水流、树木，它们是我们的亲人。所以这就像是被家人环绕着。这非常具有治愈作用。马克，你如何看待这种架构？我们经常使用“自然世界”这个词，
to describe what it's like to be in the woods or by the ocean. There is something natural. about being in nature. As Lisa says, we are one with it and it is one with us. Yes, I think that's a very powerful concept that Lisa is bringing up. And I think one thing that we sort of forget about as humans is that we evolved in nature and the world that we've kind of constructed right now is pretty new and pretty artificial. I like to joke with people that there are no straight lines in nature. You know, humans invented straight lines. And we live kind of in this straight line, boxy world. And I think we kind of distance ourselves from nature and from this environment that
来描述身处树林中或海洋旁的感觉。身处大自然之中有一种天然的。感觉。正如丽莎所说，我们与它合而为一，它也与我们合而为一。是的，我认为丽莎提出的这是一个非常强有力的概念。我认为作为人类，我们常常遗忘的一点是，我们在大自然中进化，而我们现在建造的世界相当新颖且相当人工化。我喜欢跟人们开玩笑说，大自然中没有直线。你知道，直线是人类发明的。我们生活在某种直线的、方盒子似的世界里。我认为我们在某种程度上将自己与大自然以及我们
we evolved in. And I think when we go back into nature, we feel this comfort, possibly because those are environments that we evolved in and that we spent most of our evolutionary history in. many cultures, like many indigenous cultures, really understood and valued nature and really understood nature. As we've built a world to house people efficiently and move goods efficiently, we've kind of distanced ourselves from our home environment. And I think now we maybe need to take a moment and think, you know, actually we've become too divorced from nature and that we need to really bring nature back into our lives at a very, very
进化而来的这个环境隔离开来了。我想当我们回到大自然中时，我们会感受到这种舒适感，这可能是因为那是我们进化而来的环境，也是我们度过了大部分进化史的环境。许多文化，比如许多土著文化，真正理解并珍视大自然，也真正理解大自然。随着我们为了高效容纳人口和高效运输货物而建造了一个世界，我们在某种程度上将自己与我们的家园环境拉开了距离。我想现在我们或许需要花点时间思考，你知道，实际上我们与大自然的脱节太严重了，我们需要真正将大自然以非常、非常
big scale. We received a message from a listener named Allison about the many ways in which we imbue nature with human qualities. When my husband died in 2011, I was driving
宏大的规模重新融入我们的生活。我们收到了一位名叫艾莉森（Allison）的听众发来的信息，内容关于我们将人类特质赋予大自然的多种方式。2011年我丈夫去世后，我开始开车
back and forth to work after that. And immediately, the first thing that I noticed was how problem the mountains became. And I had like San Gorgone on one side, Mount Baldi's on the other side. There's, I think there's even San Jacinto. So there's three different mountain ranges. And as I would drive to work, I would pass by the different views of each different mountain range. And the mountains became personified. And they stood for stability and strength. and they, I'm sure, you know, I animated them in my intense sorrow at the time.
上下班。立刻，我注意到的第一件事就是群山变得多么引人注目。我一边有圣戈尔戈尼奥（San Gorgonio），另一边有鲍尔迪山（Mount Baldy）。我想甚至还有圣哈辛托（San Jacinto）。所以有三个不同的山脉。当我开车去上班时，我会路过每个不同山脉的不同景色。这些山峰被拟人化了。它们代表着稳定和力量。它们，我确信，你知道，我在当时强烈的悲伤中赋予了它们生命力。
And so they made me feel like I, you know, was going to be okay. Talk a moment about this, Mark. We don't see a lake as just a body of water. We see it as peaceful. We don't see a volcano as just a geological phenomenon. It feels like it has agency. Randy told us about how when he hugged a boulder in his grief, it stood for stability in the midst of impermanence.
所以它们让我觉得，你知道，我会没事的。马克，请花点时间谈谈这个。我们并不把湖泊仅仅看作是一团水。我们认为它是平静的。我们并不把火山仅仅看作是一种地质现象。它让人感觉具有能动性。兰迪（Randy）告诉我们，当他在悲伤中拥抱一块巨石时，在无常之中，它代表着稳定。
Is it possible that some of the effects that nature has on us is because of our own tendency to anthropomorphize the world? It's an interesting idea. I think humans do naturally do a lot of anthropomorphizing of the natural world. And Allison or Randy or Anjali in their intense grief, maybe it kind of opened people their eyes a little bit, to see the natural world in maybe a different way. I remember I had my tree in Barton Park in Ann Arbor,
大自然对我们产生的一些影响，有没有可能是因为我们自身倾向于将世界拟人化？这是一个有趣的观点。我认为人类确实会自然而然地对自然世界进行大量的拟人化。艾莉森、兰迪或安贾莉（Anjali）在他们强烈的悲伤中，也许这在某种程度上稍微开阔了人们的眼界，让人类能够以一种可能不同的方式看待自然世界。我记得我在安娜堡（Ann Arbor）的巴顿公园（Barton Park）有我的一棵树，
a big, big oak tree that I, you know, I kind of used to talk to a little bit, but whenever I had some troubles or things that were really bothering me, I did like to walk in Barton Park and walk by that tree, and that tree seemed like it had a lot of wisdom. And, you know, that tree had probably been around for 200 years. And, you know, those mountains, that Allison has talked about have been there for thousands and thousands of years,
那是一棵很大很大的橡树，你知道，我过去经常跟它说说话，每当我遇到一些麻烦或者真正让我烦心的事情时，我确实喜欢去巴顿公园散步，走到那棵树旁，那棵树似乎蕴含着许多智慧。而且，你知道，那棵树可能已经存在了200年。而且，你知道艾莉森谈到的那些山峰已经在那里存在了成千上万年，
and there's just something about that they've been there for so long that it almost seems like they carry some kind of wisdom. And again, just see that we're just a part of something bigger than ourselves. One critique that we received from listeners is that our original conversation romanticized nature, Mark. One listener moved from a city to a rural area and writes, For me now, walking in nature is a high-stress situation. My dog and I are hyper-vigilant, always on the lookout for coyotes, porcupines, skunks, badgers, bears, mountain lions,
正是某种原因，因为它们在那里存在了那么久，几乎让人觉得它们承载着某种智慧。同样，这也让我们看到我们只是比自身更宏大的事物的一部分。我们收到的来自听众的一个批评是，我们最初的对话将大自然浪漫化了，马克。有一位听众从城市搬到了农村地区并写道：对我来说，现在在自然中散步是一种高压情况。我和我的狗都高度警惕，随时提防着郊狼、豪猪、臭鼬、獾、熊、美洲狮，
and worst of all, humans with unleashed dogs. In my opinion, your guest maybe hasn't spent enough time in natural settings where there are very real dangers such as wild animals and crazy humans that realize they can get away with anything because there is no one around to call for help. Walking in nature is not a panacea. What do you think, Mark? Is there a risk that many of us romanticize nature? Yeah, I think it's a really interesting point from that listener, and I definitely don't want to equate all nature experiences. I mean, sometimes when we publish our papers, people ask us,
最糟糕的是，带着未拴绳的狗的人类。在我看来，你的嘉宾可能没有花足够的时间在真正的自然环境中，那里存在着非常真实的危险，比如野生动物和疯狂的人类，他们意识到自己可以逃脱惩罚，因为周围没有人可以呼救。在自然中散步并不是万灵药。马克，你怎么看？我们当中许多人将大自然浪漫化，这是否存在风险？是的，我认为这位听众提出了一个非常有趣的观点，我绝对不想将所有的自然体验等同起来。我的意思是，有时当我们发表论文时，人们会问我们，
you know, what about a wildfire or what if you're in nature being chased by a bear? In my book, nature in the mind, I talk about one experience that I had in nature that was not restorative at all, and that was when I was hiking in the smoky mountains, and we were hiking up this one peak, and we decided to take an alternative route down. And it turned out that the path was three times longer than the one that we had taken on the way up, which meant that we started to hike in darkness, and it was terrible. It was not restorative at all. all. And we all started to fight with each other. And it really took a lot of mental energy to navigate our way down and not get into fights with each other. So it was not pleasant at all.
野火怎么办，或者如果你在自然中被熊追怎么办？在我的书《大自然与心灵》中，我谈到了我在大自然中的一次经历，那一点也没有恢复精神的效果，那就是当我在大雾山（Smoky Mountains）徒步时，我们正向其中一座山峰爬去，我们决定选择一条替代路线下山。结果证明这条小路比我们上山时走的那条路长了三倍，这意味着我们开始在黑暗中徒步，这太糟糕了。一点也没有恢复精力的效果。我们所有人都开始互相争吵。为了摸索着下山而不互相争吵，这确实耗费了大量的脑力。所以一点也不愉快。
As the listener says, if you don't feel safe in nature, we don't think it's going to be restorative. If you feel like you have to be looking over your shoulder, we don't think it's going to be restorative. So the kind of nature experiences that we've been talking about are the kinds of natural experiences where you feel safe, you can let your mind wander, you don't have to be so vigilant. I think what I'm saying is that nature is very important and we need to figure out ways to incorporate more nature into our lives, even if those lives are in a very kind of urban environment. We heard from a listener named K Bird who talked about how dealing with the cycles of nature can help us see the cycles in our own lives. On her birthday, following a very painful divorce, she visited a peaceful mountain spot to spend the day. It was October with a bright blue sky and gorgeous autumn leaves, but suddenly, sheets of rain started pouring down.
正如听众所说，如果你在自然中感觉不到安全，我们认为它就不会有恢复精力的效果。如果你觉得自己必须时刻环顾四周保持警惕，我们认为它就不会有恢复精力的效果。所以我们一直在讨论的自然体验，是那种让你感到安全、能让你的思绪漫游、不需要保持高度警惕的自然体验。我想我在表达的意思是，大自然非常重要，我们需要想办法将更多的自然融入我们的生活，即使这些生活是在非常城市化的环境中。我们听到了一位名叫K·伯德（K Bird）的听众讲述了应对大自然的循环如何能帮助我们看到自己生活中的循环。在她的生日那天，经历了一场非常痛苦的离婚后，她去了一个宁静的山间胜地度过这一天。那是十月，万里无云、碧空如洗，秋叶绚丽多彩，但突然间，暴雨倾盆而下。
I just went down this like purge. cry rabbit hole of like everything that I had just been through and I felt like I was crying with the nature and when it finally eased which I was not expecting it was like oh this isn't going to last all day I had no idea suddenly the clouds are parted and I'm staring at this beautiful mountain with these sun rays coming through and a flippin rainbow bridging across the river in front of me. It just lasted a minute. So you had to have gone through the rain to see it.
我当时就陷入了一种宣泄式的、崩溃哭泣的无底洞，把经历过的一切都宣泄出来，我觉得自己仿佛在和大自然一起哭泣，当雨势终于减弱时——这是我始料未及的——那种感觉就像是，哦，这场雨不会下一整天。我完全不知道。突然间，云开雾散，我盯着这座美丽的山，阳光透过云层洒下来，一道该死的彩虹横跨在我面前的河流上。它只持续了一分钟。所以你必须经历过风雨才能看到它。
Like you had to have stayed through the storm to see that rainbow. So I feel like something in me fundamentally shifted that day. That's another powerful story by K. Bird. And it reminds me of some research that my mentor, Steve and Rachel Kaplan did where they were looking at people who are gardeners and looking to see how gardening could also be beneficial for people. And what they noticed was that some gardeners used pesticides and different kinds of fertilizer in their garden.
就像你必须在风暴中坚持下来才能看到那道彩虹一样。所以我觉得我内心有什么东西在那天发生了根本性的转变。这是K·伯德讲的另一个充满力量的故事。这让我想起了我的导师史蒂夫（Steve）和蕾切尔·卡普兰（Rachel Kaplan）做过的一些研究，他们当时在研究园丁群体，观察园丁如何也能给人们带来益处。他们注意到的是，有些园丁在花园里使用杀虫剂和各种肥料，
And other gardeners kind of just did it more organically and just kind of let nature run its course. and Steve used to tell me that it seemed like there was more benefits for the gardeners who are gardening without the pesticides and the fertilizers that were just letting nature take its course compared to the gardeners who are gardening with fertilizers and pesticides. And why he thought that was the case was because when you're letting nature just take its course, you're not so tied to, to, everything, but if you're trying to exert so much control over that natural environment, if a plant dies or something doesn't grow accordingly the way you like, it's going to be distressing. But if you can just kind of take that level of control away and just say, you know, I'm just going to let it go the way it's going to go. It's sort of freeing. And that kind of reminds me of
而另一些园丁则更倾向于有机种植，任由大自然顺其自然。史蒂夫过去常常告诉我，对于那些不使用杀虫剂和化肥、任由大自然顺其自然的园丁来说，似乎比那些使用化肥和杀虫剂的园丁获得了更多的好处。他认为之所以会这样，是因为当你让大自然顺其自然时，你不会对所有事情都那么纠结；但如果你试图对自然环境施加太多的控制，一旦植物枯萎或者某些生长不符合你的预期，这就会令人感到苦恼。但如果你能消除这种控制欲，只是说：“你知道的，我打算顺其自然。”这会让人感到一种解脱。这让我想起了
of Kay Bird's experience. She didn't have any control of the rain coming. The rain came. It was uncomfortable and she just kind of succumbed to it, then she kind of got this reward. And again, being in nature can kind of just help us to accept that we're not always in control and that things aren't always going to work out. But that's part of life and that's part of nature. When we come back, should you take your important business meeting in the woods? You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Mark Berman is a psychologist at the University of Chicago. He is the author of Nature and the Mind,
K·伯德的经历。对于雨水的降临，她没有任何控制力。雨下了，那感觉并不舒服，她只是顺其自然地承受了，然后她就得到了这种回报。同样，身处大自然可以在某种程度上帮助我们接受这样一个事实：我们并不总是能掌控一切，事情也并不总是能如愿以偿。但这是生活的一部分，也是大自然的一部分。稍后回来，你是否应该把重要的商务会议搬到树林里开？你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。这里是《隐藏的大脑》。我是马克·伯曼，他是芝加哥大学的心理学家。他是《大自然与心灵》一书的作者，
the science of how nature improves cognitive, physical, and social well-being. Mark's research has found that humans are profoundly drawn to features that are found in nature, not just trees and grass and water, but more abstract and subtle elements. In one study, for example, he and his colleagues showed volunteers pictures of different types of buildings, some with curved edges and some with straight edges. The building facades and building interiors had no overt nature to them, but some of the buildings had more curved edges to them. Like you can imagine a building by Gaudi in Barcelona
该书探讨了自然如何改善认知、身体和社交健康的科学。马克的研究发现，人类对大自然中的特征有着深深的向往，不仅是树木、青草和水，还有更抽象、更微妙的元素。例如，在一项研究中，他和同事向志愿者展示了不同类型建筑的照片，一些建筑带有圆润的边缘，另一些则带有笔直的边缘。这些建筑的外立面和内部没有明显的自然元素，但其中一些建筑有更多圆润的边缘。就像你可以想象巴塞罗那高迪（Gaudi）设计的建筑那样，
that has a lot of curved edges versus maybe a building with more brutalist architecture that just is very boxy with just straight lines. And it turns out, in architecture, if the building has more curved edges to it, people actually rate those buildings as being more natural, and they like those buildings more, and they rate them as more comforting. So this suggests that there's something about mimicking the patterns of nature, the curved edges, the fractalness, maybe some of the colors, that if we mimic that in our built environment, that might also confer psychological benefits.
它有许多圆润的边缘，而相比之下，有些建筑采用更多的野兽派（brutalist）建筑风格，非常方正，只有直线。事实证明，在建筑学中，如果建筑有更多圆润的边缘，人们实际上会将这些建筑评价为更自然，他们更喜欢这些建筑，并将其评为更舒适。这表明，模仿大自然的图案——圆润的边缘、分形性，或许还有一些色彩——如果在我们的建筑环境中模仿这些，可能也会带来心理上的益处。
What you're saying here, Mark, is that even when we are in human-designed environments like buildings, we can still gain some of the benefits of the natural world. If these buildings are modeled after nature, a similar theme that listeners brought up is that not everyone has easy access to the great outdoors. If you live in a city, maybe it's hard to get to a wooded area. Now, I would argue that most people, of course, can at least plant a pot of flowers or vegetables wherever they live. Does nature in miniature have the same effects on our minds?
马克，你这里所说的是，即使身处人类设计的环境（如建筑物）中，我们仍然可以获得自然世界的一些益处。如果这些建筑是以大自然为蓝本建造的的话。听众提出的另一个相似主题是，并非所有人都能轻易接触到广阔的户外。如果你住在城市里，也许很难去到树林茂密的地方。现在，我要说的是，当然，大多数人无论住在哪里，至少都可以在那里种上一盆花或蔬菜。微型的大自然对我们的心灵有同样的效果吗？
Another great question, and I would say it can have benefits. So I would say that the best thing you can do is go out in real nature. But if you don't have access to go out in real nature, can you look at real nature out of a window? And if you can't look at real nature out of the window, can you bring some real nature into the home? And if you can't bring real nature into the home, because maybe you don't have good enough lighting, you can have fake plants in the home or office. And even if you can't, if you don't want to have fake plants in the home or office, we find that even just mimicking some of the patterns of nature, like curved edges and some of the fractalness and in some kind of, you know, abstract artwork
这是另一个很好的问题，我想说它确实能带来益处。所以我想说，你能做的最好的事情就是去真正的自然中。但如果你没有机会去真正的自然中，你能透过窗户看到真正的自然吗？如果你无法透过窗户看到真正的自然，你能在家里摆放一些真正的自然植物吗？如果你无法在家里摆放真正的自然植物，也许是因为光线不够好，你可以在家里或办公室里摆放人造植物。即便你不能，如果你不想在家里或办公室里摆放人造植物，我们发现，甚至只需模仿大自然的一些图案，比如圆润的边缘、一些分形性，以及在某种类型的、你知道的抽象艺术中，
or mimicking these patterns and in other textures like in carpeting or in tables might also confer some psychological benefits. So that's another thing that I write about in the book, nature in the mind, is that we can try to nature-rise all of our spaces, and that means nature-rising our indoor spaces. So in my home office where I don't have good natural light, I do have fake or artificial plants in my office. In other areas of our home where we do have good natural light, we do tend to place a lot of plants there and even rather large plants that are beautiful for us to look at. But again, because a lot of us don't have easy access to nature, is really comforting to know that we can get some of these benefits from pictures of nature,
或者在其他质感中（如地毯或桌子）模仿这些图案，也可能带来一些心理上的益处。所以这是我在《大自然与心灵》一书中写的另一件事，那就是我们可以尝试让所有的空间都充满自然气息，这意味着让我们的室内空间充满自然气息。因此，在我光线不太好的家庭办公室里，我确实摆放了假植物或人造植物。在我们家光线充足的其他区域，我们确实倾向于在那里摆放许多植物，甚至摆放对我们来说看起来很美观的较大植物。但话说回来，由于我们许多人无法轻易接触到大自然，得知我们可以从大自然的图片中获得一些这样的益处，
plants, fake nature plants, or even just mimicking some of these natural patterns. You believe that when we go outside, it might even be beneficial to leave our devices behind and perhaps even refrain from meeting up with a friend or engaging in conversation while going for a walk. Why is this, Mark? So when we did our initial studies, having people walk in nature, we took participants' cell phones from them when they went on the walk. And the reasons why we did that is because we didn't want people chit-chatting on the phone or texting on the phone when they were out in the natural environment, because that would
植物、人造自然植物，甚至仅仅是模仿其中一些自然图案，这真的令人感到宽慰。你认为当我们走到户外时，甚至可能最好把电子设备抛在脑后，也许在散步时甚至不要和朋友约会或进行交谈。马克，这是为什么呢？所以在我们最初的研究中，让人们在自然中散步时，我们在他们去散步时收缴了参与者的手机。我们这样做的原因是因为我们不希望人们在自然环境中闲聊电话或用手机发短信，因为那会
distract them from the softly fascinating stimulation in nature. We wanted all of their attention to be captured by this interesting stimulation. in nature and for people not to be distracted. People often ask me, well, what about earbuds if I'm listening to a podcast or music? And I would suggest don't do that either. You want to be able to hear all the sounds of nature as well. And you want all of your attentional capacity to be able to be captured by the interesting stimulation in nature. So many of us spend a lot of time on screens, often because we're using computers for work or for school. We heard from listener Lisa earlier. She is the indigenous woman from Canada, and she has a
分散他们对大自然中柔和迷人刺激的注意力。我们希望他们所有的注意力都被大自然中这种有趣的刺激所吸引，而不希望人们分心。人们经常问我，如果我听播客或音乐，戴着耳机怎么样？我也会建议不要这样做。你也需要能够听到大自然的所有声音。而且你需要让你的全部注意力容量都能被大自然中有趣的刺激所捕获。我们许多人花大量时间在屏幕前，通常是因为我们要么为了工作要么为了学习而使用电脑。我们之前听取了听众丽莎（Lisa）的发言。她来自加拿大的土著女性，她有一个
suggestion for all of us. We all have to work, and so in my work when I'm contacted for a business meeting, oftentimes I will ask people if they prefer to meet in a coffee shop, or would they prefer to meet on the trail? And we'll meet in the forest, and we'll do a forest walk as we have our business meeting and do our talking that way. I'd say about 95% of the time people, people, choose to meet me in the forest. And for me, that shows me that they also desire to have that connection with nature. So it makes me feel good that I can do that one small thing to try to help bring wellness into people's lives. What do you think of Lisa's suggestion, Mark? Should we ditch the corner office for the walk on the beach? I think there's a lot of truth to what Lisa is saying.
给所有人的建议。我们都必须工作，所以在我的工作中，当有人联系我开商务会议时，我通常会问人们，他们是倾向于在咖啡馆见面，还是倾向于在小径上见面？我们会去森林里见面，一边开商务会议一边进行森林漫步，用这种方式交流。我可以说，大约95%的人会选择在森林里与我见面。对我来说，这向我表明他们也渴望与自然建立这种连结。所以这让我感觉很好，因为我能做这件小事来努力帮助把健康带入人们的生活。马克，你如何看待丽莎的建议？我们是否应该放弃角落办公室，去海滩散步？我认为丽莎所说的话包含着很多真实性，
and actually I have a student, former student, Kate Shirts, who's looking at couples who might be having an argument. And if they try to talk through their conflict in nature, like on a nature walk, that yields better benefits than trying to talk through their conflict or their issues in a more urban environment or in an office setting. So it's possible that you might have a more productive meeting walking in nature than you would in an office setting. Why not try to do that on a walk in nature? It seems like a really good idea. You tell the story of your five-year-old son who has a lot of energy, and one morning he was bouncing off the walls. Pick up the story.
事实上我有一个学生，前学生凯特·雪茨（Kate Shirts），她正在研究可能发生争吵的伴侣。如果他们试图在自然环境中（例如在自然小径散步时）化解冲突，这比试图在更具城市化环境或办公室环境中化解冲突或问题能带来更好的效果。所以，在自然中散步可能会比在办公室里开一次更富成效的会议。为什么不尝试在自然散步中这样做呢？这听起来是个非常好的主意。你讲述了你那精力旺盛的五岁儿子的故事，一天早晨他在家里上蹿下跳。接着讲这个故事。
Tell me what you did. Yeah, so he was, this is a story that repeats itself. He has a lot of energy, and we're not anti-technology. We let him do some things on an iPad, but we try. to monitor that he doesn't spend too much time on it. And he was just, you know, he wasn't listening very well. He was getting a little bit irritable and impatient. And I just said, you know, enough is enough. We're going to go on the Burnham Thorpe Trail, which is, you know, very close to our house. And we're just going to walk over there. And he was very resistant to doing it. But I got his
告诉我你是怎么做的。是的，所以他当时——这是一个不断重复的故事。他精力旺盛，我们并不反对科技。我们让他玩一会儿iPad，但我们尽量。监督他不要花太多时间在上面。当时他，你知道，他很不听话。他变得有点暴躁和不耐烦。我当时就说，够了，真的够了。我们要去伯恩姆索普小径（Burnham Thorpe Trail），你知道的，离我们家非常近。我们就要走到那里去。他非常排斥这样做。但我帮他穿好了
boots on. I got his jacket on. And we went. And we probably spent about two hours. outside, you know, we found some snakes, which was really interesting. We looked at some rocks by the creek. We walked around on some trails. And his mood and his attention, you could just see how much it was improving with every minute that we were out there at my son's school. They used to have a longer recess that was 45 minutes where they could go outside for 45 minutes and kind of do whatever they want. And now they've reduced that down to about 20 minutes. And the teachers have now been telling me that they are having a lot more behavioral issues in school that they had in years past. And they're thinking part of that might be because the kids are not having as much time outside. And
靴子，穿好了夹克。然后我们出发了。我们大概花了两个小时。在户外，你知道，我们发现了一些蛇，这真的很有趣。我们在小溪边看了一些石头。我们在小径上散步。随着我们在外面待的每一分钟，你可以清楚地看到他的情绪和注意力在如何显著改善。在我儿子的学校里，
And I just think this is something that's really, really important for parents, for kids, for employers and employees that, you know, yes, that might take some time away from the desk, but you might actually gain more productivity overall because when people then sit down to work or sit down in class to learn, they're going to have more ability to focus and then will be more productive. Mark Berman is a psychologist at the University of Chicago. He is the author of Nature and the Mind, the science of how nature improves cognitive, physical, and social well-being.
他们过去有一个较长的45分钟课间休息，他们可以去户外45分钟，随心所欲地做任何他们想做的事。而现在他们把时间缩短到了大约20分钟。老师们现在一直在告诉我，他们在学校遇到的行为问题比往年要多得多。他们认为部分原因可能是孩子们在户外呆的时间不够多。而且
Mark, thank you so much for joining me again today on Hidden Brain. Thank you so much, Shankar. It was my pleasure. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy Paul, Christian Wong, Laura Quarell, Ryan Katz, Orrin Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer.
我认为这对于父母、孩子、雇主和雇员来说都是一件非常、非常重要的事情，你知道，是的，这可能会占用一些离开办公桌的时间，但你实际上可能会获得更高的整体生产力，因为当人们随后坐下来工作或在课堂上坐下来学习时，他们将拥有更强的专注能力，从而会变得更加高效。马克·伯曼是芝加哥大学的心理学家。他是《大自然与心灵》一书的作者，该书探讨了自然如何改善认知、身体和社交健康的科学。
I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you love Hidden Brain, please share this episode with one or two people in your life who would find it to be interesting or useful. Word of Math recommendations are a powerful way to help us reach new listeners and connect them with the ideas that we feature on Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
马克，非常感谢你今天再次做客《隐藏的大脑》。非常感谢你，香卡。这是我的荣幸。《隐藏的大脑》由隐藏的大脑传媒（Hidden Brain Media）制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲·保尔（Annie Murphy Paul）、克里斯蒂安·王（Christian Wong）、劳拉·夸雷尔（Laura Quarell）、瑞安·卡茨（Ryan Katz）、奥林·巴恩斯（Orrin Barnes）、安德鲁·查德威克（Andrew Chadwick）和尼克·伍德伯里（Nick Woodbury）。塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》执行主编。如果你喜欢《隐藏的大脑》，请把这一期节目分享给你生活中觉得有趣或有用的一两个朋友。口碑推荐是帮助我们接触新听众并将其与我们在《隐藏的大脑》中推崇的理念联系起来的有力方式。我是香卡·维丹塔姆。我们很快再见。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。